[Music]
foreign
three two one
[Music]
check it out
foreign
[Music]
hi
guys
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
go
laughs
[Music]
thank you
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
puzzles world championship this is day
two these are the finals I'm your host
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky alongside
me today once again women's
International Master Ana Maya Kazarian
anamaya welcome to the show thank you so
much Dania welcome back everyone I am so
excited for today's event Diana because
today we will see who becomes the
puzzles world champion I'm so excited
how about you Diane yeah we don't really
have any good puzzle solvers
unfortunately this year you know Ray
Robson uh you had Andy Woodward we had a
couple pretty pretty uh weak scores
yesterday and day one so let's review
some of the worst performances yesterday
uh starting from Ray robson's 58 points
what a surprise that Ray Robson getting
the top score nmi wherever your eyes
turn here just unbelievable scores all
around and the craziest thing is that
not all of these players qualified you
needed crazy scores for the entirety of
the event to make it into the finals
indeed and it was really awesome also to
see some new names because in previous
Edition we knew most of the names
already uh we had Men playing Ray robs
and jimmies all of those names were all
familiar but this time we see some new
names and I'm really excited to see if
they can manage to you know make some
surprises happen
and a big name that we talked a lot
about yesterday was Liam Putnam the
young fide master from the US who
unfortunately did not make it into the
knockout but he really was the star of
the show but another star of the show
Philippians 46 AKA International Master
Andy Woodward I think he's 12 or 13.
he's incredibly talented in OTB chess
and clearly indicating that he is a new
Puzzler that has arrived on the scene
and is ready to challenge Ray Robson for
Puzzle Battle domination anime it ain't
gonna be an easy Journey for Mr Ross
absolutely yeah and that's why I'm
really looking forward to see if those
youngsters today can make some surprises
because they're pretty you know new to
the tournament they haven't played in
the puzzle World Championship just yet
so we'll find out today if they can make
surprises happen
yes we will and before we get started
let's quickly review The Format and then
the bracket the format is
straightforward this is a double
elimination knockout which means you've
got two chances if you lose one match
you can make your way through the losers
bracket and challenge the winner in the
Grand Final each Puzzle Battle is going
to be uh an eight game contest so best
of eight if you win five puzzle battles
then you win the match and you advance
and uh that's basically in anemiah best
of eight right and then the losers
bracket is best of four but we'll get to
that
exactly so we have two different
brackets the winners bracket loses
bracket if you lose one of your matches
you still have a chance to win the whole
event but you will have to win a lot of
matches and that may not be so easy yeah
it sounds great oh I can just lose and
then all I have to do is win like four
matches but hey you get two chances I
love the double elimination format big
fan let's quickly review the bracket and
then we will jump into our first matches
of the day between Robson and round
accident and Dimitar mardov another one
of those young International Masters who
has revealed himself as an incredible
puzzle solver he faces the brother of
Danish Grandmaster Rasmus vain Frederick
Spain also now an OTB Grand Master and
of course Andy Woodward against
Christopher you I mean all around here
anemiah we've got amazing matches this
time
I am so excited for those matchups I
mean they're all so they their scores
are so close together I really can't
wait to see if Andrew tank can take down
uh Jimmy's Demetrius lado pulos uh one
of the best puzzle solvers uh in the
world has been in the final in the
previous editions of the puzzle wolves
championship against Ray Robson so I'm
really looking forward to see if Andrew
tank can take down one of the best
puzzle Silvers so let's find out let's
find out indeed we are all set we will
start with Ray robson's match against
Grand Master raunak sidwani and of
course what makes Rey terrifying isn't
just his ability to score 58 it isn't
just his ability to score higher than
anybody else it is his consistency he
almost never scores below
53-54 that's considered bad for Ray
Robson and that's what's so backbreaking
about it here we go anamaya oh I'm
excited Daya let's go let's go and the
players are off to the races this is our
first puzzle battle and it is a best of
eight contest Rey moving pace for pace
so far as they solve the easy ones
I mean you can tell righty Ray is not in
the rush he's not trying to solve the
puzzles as soon as possible he's taking
it easy he's not in a rush Veronica in
fact faster but will he be able to keep
this Pace on for the rest of the puzzle
Rush that's the point that's the
question that is the question both
players slowing down a little bit with
regards uh in comparison to yesterday
obviously the cost of a mistake is much
higher uh although it's not about the
cumulative score you can afford to lose
the puzzle battle here and there but you
really can't afford to lose any to Ray
Robson you're right Rey is actually down
a point right now but wait until they
get to the 30s and then Watch What
Happens yeah there we go break keeps
going
so far so good for both players they
both managed 30 in a minute
wow no mistakes yesterday I got inspired
to also trial puzzle rush if I can keep
up and uh I cannot
yeah it goes to show how insane it is
I mean look at both players no mistakes
37 for Roundup can he manage 40 before
Rey Rey kind of catching up here still
no mistakes
wow five okay ray with 38 Roundup
they're a little bit stuck but he
manages to get it still no mistakes
insane now they're on the same puzzle
they're on the same puzzle as it Bishop
E6 trapping the queen and queen takes B2
both players get it at the same time
oh my goodness that was not an easy
Checkmate 40 free for both players still
no mistakes and there's a checkmate with
root takes E3
a minute left on the clock
around not getting 45 pace for Pace they
are just neck and neck right now
is doing a fantastic job so far he
really is I think it Queen takes H3
Desperado Rey is struggling he gets it
and there's an easy one
peanut they're stuck on the same one
Bishop I think it's yeah Bishop H7 gets
it wrong
oh that's a crucial mistake right there
he has to catch up now but it's but at
this point both players can gamble
Roundup catches Rey again now both
players are gonna get 50. around X stuck
and he gets it 50 for both
can raunak score a crazy win in the game
one he's leading Ray right now and Ray
gets up 52. oh my God Ray's got to get
this one both players with 52. right now
oh my God both players to 53. oh the
second strike for Roundup another one
for Roundup he misses it and Ray wins
54 a one-point difference wow that was a
really close one
oh my lands that was absolutely
unbelievable roundak was going pace for
Pace with Ray Robson he was leading with
five seconds left and suddenly Ray gets
two puzzles in a millisecond and passes
around a welcome to Ray robson's world
wow he did that so effortlessly but I do
have to give ronak a lot of credit here
because he kept it so close throughout
the entire run the match was decided in
the final seconds
yeah it really was I mean I wasn't even
keeping up with the puzzles but the fact
that round knock has managed 53.
unfortunately that's not going to be
enough because like I said 54 is really
on the low end for Ray Robson and that
really tells you all you need to know
and I looked it up before the match
roundup's highest score in three minutes
puzzle Rush is 54. so this is one of his
highest scores so I'm really looking
forward to see if he can improve this
score during this event
yeah this was an incredible run I mean
his first mistake came really in the mid
40s which honestly you really can't ask
for anything more than that I think he
was essentially flawless I just think
Ray Robson is inhuman that's just what I
think you can have a perfect Puzzle
Battle Run and there's still nothing
that you can do
right
um did they start their second
um match already well let's take a look
oh they are uh writing writing down the
scores we will start our second Puzzle
Battle Game momentarily
and all right we also have the ND
Woodward match that I think is going to
be starting in parallel so plenty of
entertainment to go around absolutely do
you think Ray robson's feels any sort of
pressure in those puzzle battles or do
you think he's just relaxed and doing
his own thing
I think largely he's doing his own thing
he's won this event so many times that I
think he kind of knows the drill and Rey
he doesn't get too high with the highs
doesn't get too low with the lows he
just sort of I mean even if he loses an
individual game I don't think he's going
to be flustered I think he just that's
how consistent he is
mm-hmm yeah it's interesting to see that
in this uh particular run he had 54
which is a very good score that for sure
but he did make it very close and it
could have been the other way around
Rana could have won this match pretty
easily so maybe there are some chances
whether that's for roundock or the other
participants potentially to take down
rain
oh yeah and hopefully we get started
here uh momentarily but uh I just wanted
to point out another technical
clarification that if both players have
the same score but one player has more
strikes you can claim a win so let's say
roundac has 52 points and he's had three
strikes Ray gets up to 52 points and he
has one strike Ray can actually already
claim a win because in the event of a
tied score the player with less strikes
actually wins The Puzzle Battle the
individual contest by tiebreaker okay
here we go
and we are watching
the uh mardov Savannah match actually
okay let's take a look
um they're already in their first uh
battle
I think this was this is the second one
Sven oh okay Sven losing the first one
okay
do we have any information on what the
score was I think it was like 39 to 41
and uh oh wow oh but we're not we're not
actually we're not actually we're
looking at it on our end
um yeah but it does appear that Spain is
on the cusp of coming back in the second
Puzzle Battle we'll keep you posted on
that score
yep we're making sure that the feed is
uh working
behind the scenes and we will get the
ray uh the second Puzzle Battle started
with Ray Robson
uh in just a moment here
but yeah uh this situation did occur in
the savannah match where both players
had I think 41 points but Frederick
Savannah had more strikes in mardov
claiming the win here we go here's the
ray match
this is Puzzle Battle number two buckle
up
okay once again ronak ahead one point
taking the lead
21-21 still no strikes for both flares
they're both managing to get right
around 30 in a minute which is really
impressive in a in a puzzle battle
context again round knock leading by
four points now
wow wait look at that speed okay now
he's slowing down a little bit but still
ahead two points now
yup but Ray's starting to catch up in a
strike for right about slipped oh that
was a tough tough rough mistaken Ray of
course he ain't making the same mistake
no this is this is bad this is very bad
news around like you cannot afford to
strike this early now he's got to be
perfect
yeah that's the tough part as you go up
the score you have to be uh very precise
I mean rate solves them so effortlessly
and the puzzles get tougher
they do indeed Bishop C6 Queen C7
there's a mate for roundock still
keeping Pace but he's got that one
strike and that's gonna come in handy or
that's the opposite of that that's gonna
haunt him when they hit the 40s can
roundock rush through the 40s without
another strike
for now he's keeping up but now ready to
delete with 42 versus 41 and round up
slowing down actually right there both
stuck here yeah Knight B5 was trapping
the queen tough move but Ronald gets it
and now Rey has jumped out ahead he
still has no strikes and he shows no
signs of slowing down
here he goes again
45 with 55 seconds left that's just
incredible
he's gonna get 50 for sure easy clap
there Bishop no Queen takes E3 and
there's a back rank mate there
roundac can he get it yes he can
he does oh weren't you seven that's
still very close Queen takes C6 there
was a very tempting move but neither
player falling for it
oh my God Knight D1 his mate
50 for Ray and Counting Bishop g70
doesn't work oh it does oh Bishop H6 at
the end unbelievable
oh my gosh this is ridiculous
52 I mean he's gonna win this then
there's no chance for rounding 53 I mean
look at the look at this speed
wow
no this is this is illegal
he's just doing it at the constant Pace
like he doesn't slow down he doesn't
speed up he's he's doing it one by one
and at the same pace
and that's what kills you right because
you you saw the first 30 35 a lot of
this guy ain't that fast what's all the
fuss about and then as you said he
solves the 40s and 50s at exactly the
same rate no pun intended rate uh and
there's just no competing with that
there they go again great leading with a
score of two to zero roundock needs to
strike right now because this is getting
away from him already
he had a small delay there at the start
oh wake up every second counts when
you're playing Ray Robinson
okay yeah yeah he's down to you not okay
he's catching up he's catching up
goes so fast insane Rook B8 yeah so far
so good for both players and an easy
mate there with C5
okay
and you want to try to I think the only
way I think to even have any chance
against Ray is to build up a big
advantage in the first like minute and a
half otherwise you have zero chances
not doing that
yeah every second Collins here
yep
yeah Rook G4
Bishop take oh what okay I think because
he sold it so quickly the the last move
was shown on the screen yeah sometimes
the the moves literally the server
doesn't process the speed at which the
moves are played
laughs
okay 35 for Rey and there we go see
round Knight doesn't have that lead
after the first 90 seconds I think it's
already hopeless
no just watch I mean that rage is gonna
eat him alive here
he's just not making any mistake it's
incredible has he made a single mistake
in this entire Puzzle Battle contest I
think he's made one
could be
okay so far so good for Round Rock I
mean we gotta tip our hats to him he's
doing great
he is certainly there's just nothing you
can do
yeah I mean
yeah I mean Rey has put so much time
into puzzle rushes I mean he spent he
has spent so many uh puzzle rushes and I
don't think Raonic has the same type of
experience
but he's doing a fantastic job
most certainly yes 45 Veronica Ray is
stuck and roundock can he get this one
and get ahead I don't know what it is
Rook G1 simply oh it's a quiet move it's
those I think Rook B1 is tempting but
wrong
oh roundock stuck as well he's gotten it
but Ray gets 48.
oh what's this one Tater tight oh not
anymore Ray's gonna get 49 and round
what was that gets it too this is gonna
be a close one
50. it is oh and there goes Ray
50 for Roundup nice oh this is down to
the wire 51. 10 seconds left Roundup
gets it too oh Beret gets 52 and Rhonda
gets a strike Ray's gonna win Ray's
gonna win that's it even if Roundup gets
it
and he doesn't wow another one point
difference
oh this is insane and roundock with the
Applause there on his camera he's like
what do I gotta do to beat this guy
it it feels nearly impossible he is
playing it so precisely and he just
doesn't really need to speed up he
doesn't have any strikes
he does not and they're starting again
this is the best of eight contest so if
Rey wins this battle
he's going to be leading 4-0 I mean
listen we know what the result of this
is going to be let's check out our other
ongoing battle between Frederick savane
and Dimitar mardov
um we are going to switch
over to that contest and we'll bring you
the score in just a second this is round
three of eight I think they have one a
piece but let's confirm that
yeah so swana seems to have won the one
match
um one run and the other ones were tight
can you believe that
the other ones were oh there is a
possibility of a tie that is true
and both of them have already a strike
man after watching Rey it's like a
breath of fresh air to slow down a
little bit
makes us feel a little bit better you
know
okay
so far neither side getting any
separation both of them with a strike
yeah and the same puzzle as well it
always feels better when you're you know
you have a strike and your your opponent
makes the same mistake it kind of makes
you feel better and uh yeah you're on
the same level more or less but here
Frederick swanna is leading by Five
Points which is quite a big gap yeah it
totally makes you you're right it makes
you feel validated when you get the same
one wrong so far Savannah yeah he's
keeping that five point lead mardov he
doesn't need to panic but he will need
to catch up at some point pretty soon
because this lead otherwise is going to
balloon out of proportion good job by
martoff he is catching up E2 I think is
the move but then rookie four and then
F5 oh Savannah misses F5 after E2 it's a
tough one totally he's hard stuck E2 and
F5
finals but that took him a long time
that let mardov catch up
yeah but still had now three points now
um now mordov is stuck on this puzzle
yeah for some reason that move F7 F5 to
distract The Rook causing a lot of
problems for both players
it doesn't feel like the Rook was stuck
there whatsoever on the e-file it has it
has so many scores available but yep it
was indeed stuck there
yep and Swanee Wheeling his King out for
41 another strike for Dimitar mardov
this is a disaster of a run so far he
has to be perfect from this point on
good job a few seconds left
mm-hmm
oh I don't think he's got a chance
nope two strikes I mean two strikes
alone is already a big pressure you have
to perform well you cannot make any sort
of mouse slip whatsoever and he's on
three strikes already
39 ain't gonna cut it it ain't gonna cut
it and it doesn't even matter at this
point Savannah could claim to win he's
gonna build it all the way up I think to
50.
uh just for the heck of it and oh yeah
okay
okay 50 for Frederick spawn 80 crushes
Dimitar Marta and he does build up his
average right so it is important to get
the high score in order for your average
score to be higher in the event of a 4-4
tie right
yep the total score will count towards
the tie so you gotta have a high score
there and it seems like frederickswana
has a really nice score added up to his
total but he needs to win the matches as
well let's see what happens in this run
as oh Frederick Swanee on an early
mistake there
yeah that is very costly just like in
the last run
um okay Queen takes a 6 or 95. Savannah
just has to put it behind him I mean
this is how these disaster runs happen
you get an early strike it gets into
your head and then before you know it
you're tilting away and making another
strike
yeah and since it's a puzzle battle you
don't have the possibility of just you
know starting new run and start all over
again you have to keep going and it's so
important to have you know your
composure uh at all times uh okay
30 for both very very fast despite the
strike for both players
it appears that the score is three to
two
right now in mardov's favor
anything can still happen oh absolutely
but since we've been watching it seems
like Rasmus or Frederick has been the
better solver but perhaps those early
strikes is what has cost them thus far
um
oh two strikes now
that is very very rough
yep very sloppy there 40 he does hit 40
but if he gets one more strike it's all
over
Rook E6 I think
good job and then takes and D6
one strike for Dimitar
okay the score is tied 43 but that extra
strike for for Frederick might really
hurt him
yep because once frederickswana gets
that third strike all uh Dimitar mardov
needs to do is get to the same score and
claim the win that's it
indeed he does 46 now for Frederick he's
keeping putting the pressure
foreign
[Laughter]
48 now for Frederick
it's Bishop
very nice and just B5 B6 he's gonna get
50.
25 seconds left on the clock
or is he gonna get fancy oh it's Rook C1
and queen say it's Queen takes E4 it's
Queen takes rook in Frederick's position
right he doesn't look F1
there is a chance of simply waiting out
that's it can claim the win he can claim
the win
and he does
it's over
mardov wins this battle and he he goes
up to four so if he wins one more I
think it's over it's four two
it is for two wow that was a really
close battle once again and yeah
unfortunately for Frederick Swan and he
was not able to be so accurate as he
should be the young International Master
Dimitar mardov is announcing himself as
a serious Puzzler and Frederick needs to
go perfect now one more loss even a draw
wins this particular battle for Dimitar
mardov
yeah and that is again an early strike
Daya
yeah he's just too way too sloppy in the
first 20 puzzles I mean every run he's
had at least one strike and once it
didn't cost him but the last couple
times it did
and martov is just we're careful
yeah you got to be very careful in
puzzle battles one mile slip can make
the difference of the entire run so
yeah let's see if he can recover from
this for now he's on 27 about two or
three points ahead of Dimitar mardov
can he keep it up
Rook G7
Rook D5 okay looks like Swanee again is
ahead by three oh no oh yeah what before
foreign
we're barely able to spot the actual
puzzles because they're going so fast
and yeah the system is barely able to
keep up with them and before the three
strikes that's it I mean that's it
martov can claim the win right now
mardov can claim the win right now
and Frederick is he's upset and remember
just came to win yeah he does he does
and let's actually try to understand
where did Fredericks funny keep making
mistakes at the start so here's an
example of his his sloppiness I'm gonna
pull up the puzzle that he got wrong
early
um
I'm going to try to pull it up
I'm attempting to pull it up
um
or any other puzzle uh it basically what
he was doing is he was pre-moving right
he saw the right idea and he wasn't
looking for other details in the
position so he was moving too fast there
was a queen that was hanging in that
puzzle and instead of trading queens and
then trapping the bishop he trapped the
bishop immediately leaving his Queen
hanging so it was that you know when
you're not experienced in Puzzle Battle
sometimes you make moves too quickly
sometimes you make moves too slowly and
then when you watch Ray Robson that's
what Perfection looks like
yeah yeah indeed and it those tiny
details are what matter so much I mean
you cannot afford to have such an early
mistake you have to be very precise in
the first 20 and from there keep going
with a similar pace
Dimitar mardov he knocks out Frederick
savane the end of the first round
sending Frederick to the losers bracket
where he will have to step up his game
in a big way uh if he wants to stay in
the tournament anime I mean this isn't
gonna not gonna cut it
indeed uh those scores I mean of course
they're still really impressive scores
but for this world championship you need
much more to be able to keep with very
experienced players like Ray robs and
Jimmy's all those players are so
experienced in puzzle Rush especially
the three-minute ones it is really hard
to keep up with this amount of scores
and the accuracy that they have you
it's unbelievable you're watching the
puzzles World Championship we are going
to go on our first break of the day when
we come back we're gonna have Andy
Woodward for you we're of course gonna
have jamaco's Demetrius ladopoulos uh
more puzzle juggernauts are waiting for
you on the other side of this break
we'll be right back
foreign
is a special time the Tata steel super
tournament is the Wimbledon of Chess all
of the greatest players in the last half
century and beyond have made the wintry
journey to vican Zay and play and won
there's a rook of seven Shaq boom Rook
takes D4 immediately played in 2023 the
reigning world chess champion Magnus
Carlson returns in the hopes of winning
his ninth title
Tata steel is famous for its tournament
lineup featuring a creative mix of
superstars and super talents that always
guarantees Fighting Chess what a
devastating moment chess.com will be
bringing you the action the drama and
the emotions Live January 13th through
January 29th don't miss history in the
making
get out
[Music]
that's right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
go
wrong
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzles World
Championship GM Daniel naritzki women's
International Master anime Kazarian
bring you coverage of today's Final this
is The Knockout Puzzle Battle final
featuring gray Robson Demetrius
lidopoulos and other Puzzle Battle
juggernauts we just watched Ray Robson
dismantle round exoduani and of course
he makes it into the winners bracket now
and Amaya we are about to watch Andrew
Tang Andy Woodward Demetrius lenopoulos
and others fight for the second half of
the first round
yes I am so excited for these matches
these matches feel super close and we
have new names and the Woodward we have
not seen him play puzzle Rush before
other than yesterday but it's his first
time as far as I'm concerned uh that
he's participating in a puzzle World
Championship so I'm really looking
forward to see if he can make something
happen here today uh as well as seeing
if Jimmy's can still take on Andrew Tang
or is Andrew tank capable of defeating
jimius I can't wait I can't wait either
let's get the show on the road Demetrius
I mean the guy is insane he has the
smallest board that's anyone ever used
in the history of humanity we don't know
how he manages to do that but you know
you talk about putting in raw hours
hours and hours and hours Demetrios
might be the only one to compete with
Ray Robson in terms of number of hours
spent solving puzzle Russian doing
Puzzle Battle
exactly so I'm really curious to see if
he can still live up to that uh because
you know Andrew tank has been practicing
we saw him yesterday you know at God
speed solving the puzzles and we know
how quick he is uh generally when he
plays chess so maybe we can see surprise
today
I think that Andrew he's incredibly fast
in the first minute we know that he is
the fastest in the world in the first
minute of solving but he has to avoid
sloppy Solutions in the first 30 35
puzzles you cannot get a strike against
gymnast it's the same thing against Rey
you just cannot afford to have that
burden sitting on you as you're trying
to get through the 40s and the 50s and
you know if you're Andrew Zhang you're
gonna have to put in 53-54 basically
every run and then it's in God's hands
after that
absolutely so it is a tough match
rendered tank but I can't wait to see
that one what do you think about Andy
Woodward versus Crystal for you we saw
Christopher you yesterday playing on his
tablet once again it he had a really
amazing overlay I really have to ask him
how he did that but what do you think of
that one
that was Sleek I feel like Andy Woodward
might suffer from some Nerfs because I
can tell you I've done this Puzzle
Battle World Championship now a couple
times as a player and uh you know for me
playing the very first time I could
barely manage 30. it was like I had
forgotten how to solve made in one
puzzles and it's just that effect of
knowing everybody's watching you and
it's different from puzzle rush because
you're actually playing somebody and
you're watching your opponent's score go
up so when you're doing it for the first
time I think Andy Woodward he's just
gonna have to put the nerves aside
pretend that this is a puzzle Rush
pretend that he's just solving puzzles
in the park and uh you know do your best
but we're gonna watch Andy Woodward's
nerves
um and if you're uh if you're his
opponent then obviously you want him to
get those early puzzles wrong
exactly it's the most intimidating thing
when you're playing to hear your
opponent's score go up you hear this
sound sound it is the most intimidating
thing ever and I believe they just
started Anya they didn't especially if
you're stuck on a puzzle there's nothing
worse than what you're gonna rack up the
total gymnast with a mouse slip of the
first six puzzles
look at Andrew's speed he's on the 11
already oh Jimmy's Mouse slipped I think
he meant to play Queen B2 instead of
Queen B3 but now jimis has to rack up
the point total he can't afford another
strike in the early going
absolutely and now Andrew on 20 already
or barely 30 seconds have passed can he
keep up the space
so far so good Andrew's goal is to get
30 in a minute he's going to manage that
I think he's going to manage that with
seconds to spare
yeah insane
there's 20. there's 29 and there's no
more than 30.
that's what he wants
gymnast is stuck Rook takes G7 there as
the move the gymnast is struggling with
he plays it
yeah but look at the difference Andrew
now as I had seven points on the
scoreboard he needs to keep this up but
again I'm gonna say the same thing I
said when watching right
how fast is Jim is gonna be when he gets
to the 40s right that's where they
really rack it up and Andrew getting one
wrong now they both have a strike and
this is bad news for Andrew Tang
it is still he's still ahead on the
score but slowly but surely Jim is is
catching up he is on 37 now and time is
running down
and Andrew is stumped I think A3 is the
move that he's blanking on trapping the
queen
come on Andrew A3 is basic Brian here
and B4 that took him way too long but
Jim is now a little bit stuck as well
I think
B1 no then H6 what's the move here
Jim is talking
Ruby play Rook B1 and promote with Chuck
oh rugby one H6 me too he doesn't see it
and he finally doesn't make a challenge
one check exactly now Queen V8 and the
room
Andrew's got a huge strike
oh my God Andrew might win this first
battle Andrew with a second strike jimis
has to get seven in uh Rook A4 he's Jim
is totally blanking on easy moves
30 seconds left Andrew is ahead seven
points out both on two strikes this is
looking very good for Andrew even if
Andrew gets a third strike right now
which he shouldn't he should be
conservative
no that there's no way James is getting
six in 10 seconds is there is there
no he's not gonna make it Andrew's
gotten a 46th one third strike as well
that's it Jim is loses the first game
that was a really good run by Andrew he
had 30 in less than a minute which was
insane and that made it much easier for
him as well to finish with a win here
unbelievable but we have actually seen
this in previous years I seem to
remember that Jim has also lost the last
in last year's contest he lost the first
game as well it may have been the case
that his screen froze because he is very
slow
uncharacteristically slow in the first
bosses there he goes That's the gymnast
we all know and love now now we're
talking now we're talking he's back now
we're speaking a language that I
understand
but look at Andrew on 19 already still
going you're gonna get another 31 in a
minute
he's on Pace to get right about 30.
no he's a little bit slower this time
more like 25.
oh there he goes there he goes
before he could even say it 27 can he
manage 30 in a minute and Jim is with
another strike oh my gosh
tough one
Andrew's gonna manage a very solid 28 in
a minute
a little slower than the previous one
but still on track still had six points
now and Jimmy is stuck here has jimis
lost some of that magical Greek touch
he's down eight points he's got a strike
Andrew's got a clean slate here
and he's keeping that eight point lead
alive
still an eight-point lead
wow Andrew on the roll here total roll
nine point lead
can he make it extend it to 10 while Jim
is stuck
yes he can yep
oh this is a humongous lead
but she's doing an amazing job
still at eight I mean there's a minute
left Jim is just gonna run out of time
here at some point he's got to start
catching up and he is
six
back to seven though
one minute on the clock left Andrew's
taking it a little bit easier now but is
that is it enough for demons to catch up
I'm not sure now five point difference
though you can just see Jim is creeping
up it was at eight now it's at five
it's back to six though Andrew he's not
he's not taking his foot off the gas
pedal at all can he make it to 50 yes he
can Andrew's just amazing solving here
oh and Jim is with a really hard one
there and he got it
and 30 seconds it's still at five and
now it's at four
oh look at this puzzle of uh Andrew oh
my gosh
it's back to a four point lead I think
Jim Miss might not be able to make it no
he got one instantly
it's back to a three-point lead 10
seconds left though no it's over there's
no way James gets four in three seconds
Andrew's gonna win another one and he's
got 55.
wow almost flawlessly there by Andrew
Tang what a massive score no this is
insane Andrew Tang wins the first two
battles against Demetrius lidopoulos
perhaps the second in command in terms
of Puzzle Battle favorite after Ray
Robson
this is stunning right now and
congenital himself together
yeah I mean Andrew Tang is on a crazy
speed here he's playing better than
yesterday one can argue and remember he
almost got eliminated yesterday he
squeaked through with the last run
you're absolutely right to avoid
elimination and what a story it would be
if at the very least he makes it into
the finals okay here we go jimus has to
stop the bleeding if he loses another
one you know Andrew's already knocking
on the door of sending Demetrios to the
losers bracket
okay
and they say in the chat that Demetrius
always comes back in the end we'll see
given Andrew's confidence right now I
don't know
31 in two minutes in a minute
I mean Andrew has been ahead every
single match now every single puzzle
restaurant he is ahead a couple of
points that definitely gives him a lot
of confidence but this is this is
looking better for Demetrios he doesn't
have any strikes and he is keeping
keeping Pace thus far he's keeping
within two or three and if I think if
Demetrios can stay Within two or three
puzzles when they hit the 40s he's the
favorite let's see whether Demetrios can
deliver here
yes he can he's catching up
yeah Andrew has slowed down
significantly so there is a chance for
demons to catch up now
well there's no question that jimus is
faster at the 40s puzzles it's just that
Andrew's lead was so big previously that
it didn't matter right now though it's
much closer
much closer Rook takes F1 made in two
Andrews not seeing it
who allows Demetrius to catch up
he misses it it's literally made in two
I can't believe it that was a tough one
to spot because they told us the king
had all squares available on the board
pretty much
this is gonna be a really close one
Dimitrius gets one wrong
okay but what is this puzzle that Andrew
is solving right now
it's ridiculously hard
gets it right
neck and neck right now oh a second one
Demetrios gets 50. he's gonna win this
one I think
looks like there's 30 seconds left on
the clock now he's gone he's gone
he's gone that's it
three strikes and Jimmy's wins this run
so it's 2-1 for Andrew Tang
may it be true that Jimmy is coming back
and Bishop takes E7 there was the move
first gymnast is gonna get 52.
which for him is a is a serviceable
score but nothing spectacular
but most importantly he comes back he
strikes back and the score is one to two
and Andrew Tank's favor it almost
doesn't feel like you're beating jimus
like it it never feels like he's out of
the contest obviously
because of his reputation
yeah
another early strike for Jimmy's oh my
gosh just way too sloppy at this age
jittery and it just doesn't seem like
he's got the pace down
yeah I'm not sure what's going on but
this is very
characteristic for him and again Andrew
has built up the early you know seven
eight point lead if he can maintain that
it's gonna be a repeat of their second
Rush yeah
I mean Andrew Tang on 25 already uh 40
seconds have passed now and he's gonna
get another 30 plus here in one minute
indeed he is
okay 31. wait this this is even faster
than the first run
he could manage I mean we science we got
35 yesterday in a minute which is the
fastest that I have ever seen 33 this
time I mean that's unbelievable
wow
yeah in terms of raw speed Andrew is the
fastest player on the planet I truly
believe that in terms of like raw
speed of movement and he got someone
wrong
it seems very logical Rook A4 Bishop to
A6 and then Rook takes Bishop is the
solution there he gets it
but the lead is shrinking
wow Jimmy's catching up there already at
34.
it was down over five point
not anymore now it's at three but it
feels very precarious
very precarious
here's the mate
oh I hate those puzzles that Andrew just
had oh they feel so sophisticated it's
like one of those studies you know yeah
studies in general are so hard to get in
Puzzle Battle
I mean I I anytime I see a knight
somewhere in like two minor pieces I
know I'm not getting it yeah yeah like
this one Rook D1 Rook D2 take the bishop
Rook G1 and King B3 with zuzvong on the
bishop and Jim has got it in like a
millisecond
yeah G4 it's made in three G4 Rook H6
and Bishop H4 F4
you got set you get it
he cuts it
I couldn't I couldn't decide whether I
want to say you got it or he gets it the
same so he gots it
[Music]
Andrew's leading and Jim is for the
second strike
how did this happen
it seems like Jim is simply slowed down
two strikes oh another strike for Andrew
can Jim is catch up here in the last 10
seconds got 48. oh he's got to get it
immediately
49. Andrews probably shouldn't wait oh
Insurance
Queen d8 was the move Queen to d8 with
mate on G5 in the onion to Andrew wins
again
unbelievable it's three two one for
Andrew Tang
incredible Andrew with a big lead
should we check into our other match
between Andy Woodward
and um
whoever Andy Woodward's playing Krista
for you and Andy Woodward's opponent
all right here we go yeah let's take a
look all right off we go to our other
parallel match
between Woodward and Christopher you
they are locked in a very tight battle
right now
we'll bring you their score their score
ladies and gentlemen is three to one in
Angie Woodward's favor
and Andy Woodward wins another one he's
got Christopher you against the wall
oh this is unbelievable
he has a massive advantage over there I
mean
um looking at the scores he he already
stopped it at 36 because Christopher you
had three strikes already Krista for you
with a meltdown here in this battle and
listen Andy Woodward is up one two three
four to one if he wins one more
that's it it's over even if he makes a
draw Andy Woodward advances to the next
stage sending Christopher to the loser's
bracket let's see if he can finish off
the job this is where the nerves come in
though anime this is where you start
feeling the jitters absolutely then now
they're at the same score they have the
same Pace at this very start so that's
at least looking good for both but who
has this pace till the very end let's
see
that's the million dollar question and
some problems there
okay King H6 and okay I didn't really
follow that one but
it goes by like you blink and it's gone
let's buy like a Ferrari on a racetrack
I mean oh there's another oh what am
what am I telling you that am I oh and
there's one tool they got the same one
oh Christopher has his chances here
it feels like Andy has a slight slight
Advantage here as he's a little bit
faster
Christopher might be the one suffering
from nerves he's usually a lot faster
than this
a lot more precise too
if you wouldward he's just a Phenom
you do not want to face that guy over
the board let me tell you
delete no
so if Christopher loses even a single
more battle it's over Andy Woodward gets
to Five Points and he gets a second
strike oh that is very expensive
don't shovel dirt on him yet and there's
a second strike for Christopher
but it's this one that Andy niece's Soul
still so this is not looking good for
Andy he's currently stuck but he does he
find it he finds it yeah he does it
does Chris now he's three points
E4 what a move oh Jesus
H3 and Knight F5
is what Andy's struggling with right now
H3 and Knight F5 and Knight takes G7
General I'm telling you he he would be
much faster on these but he senses that
he's so close to winning
and Christopher is pulling away
yeah he's taking a huge lead now 47
already we're still 30 seconds to go
this is the Christopher we know and love
he's gonna hit 50 I think
barring a third strike there's 49.
rookie eight I think rookie eight
he's not seeing it rookie eight and he
got it
good here comes Andy Woodward 47. oh oh
he got third strike now
Christopher you saves
saves the match and lives to fight
another day or let's just say another
battle because it's right about to start
what's going on the other one between
Andrew and Demetrios maybe we can uh
just find that information out because
this is fascinating this one is so
entertaining
absolutely by the way in dimitrios's
match against Andrew
Andrew one Andrew one oh and dimitrios
winning their fifth so it's two to three
in Andrew's favor that one's also very
close but let's stay on this one
let's see
so both players are pretty fast at the
beginning they have similar speed
um they're not as fast as we saw Andrew
tank solve those puzzles but they have a
good pace they have a good Pace it's
really what I'm learning about this year
is that it's all about avoiding the
early strikes I think the players who
get that strike before let's say the
30th puzzle or before the 35th puzzle
are are just it's just so hard to come
back from that in most cases and so far
both players very clean
yeah no strikes
and they are about to hit 30 more
minutes maybe maybe not
yeah I think Andy will definitely hit 30
in a minute
and probably so will Christopher yep he
does 30 and Counting
wow
very impressive
oh Jim is might have just tied it at
three and there's a strike for
Christopher oh a big one
we cannot afford that it's a very close
one the second one oh he's he's
collapsing
yeah you cannot afford that he needs an
absolute Miracle right now because those
are puzzles that were solvable now he's
got to get those right on the other end
no and I think if Andy doesn't destroy
himself right now he's gonna win
yeah I mean he's ahead on the on the
scoreboard he doesn't have any strikes
it's very comfortable position for him
but if you're Andy you got to step on
the gas pedal and you got to make sure
that you got the time to take your time
you don't need to do anything crazy
Knight D2 was the move there oh that was
an easy one
oh my gosh Andy feeling the nerves here
Christopher has basically caught up on
the score
but he's got those two strikes and that
might cost him
yeah oh this is a really beautiful
checkmate
Queen takes D5 and queen B5 or queen D7
oh Andy Woodward is on fire
Knight D6 check and queen takes H6 no he
got one he misses it Christopher catches
up all my lands oh it's completely tight
now crazy and Andy with 48 but
Christopher not to be outdone they're
neck and neck right now
Andy wins if he wins this battle
what's the solution here I don't see it
oh he lost queen beat oh he hasn't he
just choked it and he choked it oh
close one
but he had no strikes to Christopher's
two anemiah and a five-point lead it's
the nerves and Christopher you
ties the battle it's gonna come down to
the eighth battle
oh wow it is in anyone's hands Krista
for you has been catching up now and he
has done that he's done a great job
and the other one is also neck and neck
their type 3-3 but this is gonna be the
final battle here we go
here we go
wait Andy is uh having a small delay at
the start over there dad is gonna hurt
him a lot
I think his hands are just shaking oh
Christa for you if he pulls this off
will be honestly one of the greatest
Puzzle Battle comebacks we've ever seen
I mean he was down I had to go with the
other one wrong another early strike for
Christopher he did that last time
could you see the whole screen shaking
oh Christopher
it's unbelievable the tension is crazy
but so far Andy Woodward with a clean
record
both of them neck and neck
yeah so far Andy is ahead one but this
does not mean anything
27-27
28 28 29 29 they're literally going neck
and neck right now
but Andy Woodward holds the lead he's
got zero strikes to one
I see a good point being made in this
Chad Diana Christopher needs to win this
with a five point difference because it
will come down if Christopher wins it
comes down to a tie and since
Christopher's on Five Points he needs a
five point advantage to you know tie it
up or win this
by the way the other matches is super
super close as well I mean listen we
can't have both at the same time here's
the second strike for any Woodward and
Christopher might not need
to get a five point lead Andy Woodward
is self-destructing here
and Christian for you has the best
chance he's had all match
he's has a lead now
oh wait start strike that's it oh that's
it Christopher you wins Andy Woodward
choked a three-point lead and what a
comeback by Christopher you I mean the
guy is insane we gotta go to the other
match though we gotta go to the other
match urgently let's skip because this
one's over this one's over can we go to
the Andrew tank match because he's
leading 4-3
okay I'm switching to the other match
It's the final battle in Andrew tank
against ledopolis
all right let's go let's go let's go
let's go it's four to three in Andrew
Tank's favor
can Jim is hold on
oh this is very very tense
Andrew Tanga had right now on the score
26-22 he has the speed again but nurse
might have come into play here
oh first strike I Was Wrong by the way
as to the Christopher you match it is
actually tied I think but anyways let's
watch this right now
Andrew tang with a strike and Demetrius
ladopoulos Tai this match at four a
piece
oh Queen you wanna what is that
Christopher you has one confirmed
foreign
strikes they have killed him in this
Puzzle Battle Andrew tank still leading
by two
he's doing a great job with that with
this Pace on the accuracy but can he
keep this up in the 40s that is a
question because that's where we know
genius is strong pure nerves right now
both players taking their time they're
stumped on their respective Bishop A6
Andrew doesn't see a maiden one
oh my God this is like crazy nerves and
he finally finds it but that took him
about 15 seconds longer than it should
have that can cost him big time and
Demetria sees it immediately
but he's got two strikes Demetrius is on
two strikes indeed
he cannot afford to get one wrong here's
two strikes from Andrew
oh my God this is down to the wire oh my
God
fine
it's tied and both players thumbs on the
same problem dimitrios gets Sid yes
it's 44 a piece
45 for Demetrios
45 for Andrew oh 20 seconds left Tanya I
think the move is Knight takes C4 and
queen A5 but I'm not sure dimitros has
stopped Andrew gets her third strike oh
and Demetrios can claim the win and he
shows you should not try to do this no
it's tied
he claims it and that means
who won dimitrios won
because he's got the higher overall
total
oh my goodness no match
no way and Andrew Tang if he got if he
had gotten this one correct would have
probably won this Puzzle Battle and
knocked out Demetrius lidopoulos at
least into the losers bracket
unbelievable it came down to the wire
entrance I was doing so well throughout
this match
unbelievable that this was honestly
amazing both matches came down to the
wire Christopher you pulls off the
comeback and wins beats Andy Woodward
coming down from three battles down
all the way to defeat him and of course
Demetrius ledopoulos he stays alive he
will have to step up his game if he
wants to defeat Ray Robson and we are
going to go on a short break ladies and
gentlemen we will take a breather and
let the players do the same you're
watching the puzzles World Championship
will go on a slightly longer break and
set the players up for the next round
we'll be back soon
January is a special time the Tata steel
super tournament is the Wimbledon of
Chess all of the greatest players in the
last half century and beyond have made
the wintry journey to vican Zay and
played and won there's a rook F7
boom Rook takes D4 immediately played in
2023 the reigning world chess champion
Magnus Carlson returns in the hopes of
winning his ninth Title
One
Tata steel is famous for its tournament
lineup featuring a creative mix of
superstars and super talents that always
guarantees Fighting Chess what a
devastating moment chess.com will be
bringing you the action the drama and
the emotions Live January 13th through
January 29th don't miss history in the
making
foreign
see you
[Music]
foreign
go
wrong
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzles World
Championship it's been non-stop
entertainment thus far on this the
second and final day of the puzzle World
Championship alongside doubling women's
International master and Amaya Kazarian
and Amaya Ray Robson Ray Robson and
Grandmaster Ray
dot dash Robson that is who you're
afraid of in this tournament
he is insane he is a machine he sews
puzzles so effortlessly and at such a
consistent Pace he is terrifying to play
against I I'm really curious to see if
anyone can take this man down but so far
he is crushing it and he will be facing
uh Dimitar mardov in his next match
yes he will he will indeed be facing
mardov with um jimus who beats Andrew
Tang by the skin of his teeth in the
Winner's bracket as well but again you
have to step it up if you're gonna play
Ray demise from Marta fresh off his
first round win against Grand Master
Fredericks vane
and he needs basically a minimum of 50
points in every single run let's see if
the young International Master could not
pull it off
absolutely for those who are just tuning
in everyone we have a Winner's bracket
and a loser's bracket those who have
lost their matches are moving to the
losers bracket and still have a chance
to win the whole event they are still
playing so they're not eliminated right
away but of course if you lose both uh
your first match and in the losers
bracket you're out
and here we go Ray Robinson taking a
couple seconds to gather himself and
we've already talked about this so many
times he is not the fastest solver in
the first minute he's actually far from
the fastest solver he doesn't try to go
for 30. he doesn't try to hit a
particular goal he just tries to avoid
strikes I think he's even mentioned that
that is literally his only goal in the
first 30 35 puzzles as long as it takes
I think that is super crucial I mean uh
from speaking from experience I know
that having this be as important so I
can spend some time on the tougher
puzzles but Ray Robson does not need
this he can solve the puzzles at the
same pace and he tries to avoid all
those strikes as much as possible and
that's just beautiful well so far his
opponent is avoiding them as well martov
okay holding a two-point lead but that's
totally meaningless let's see if he can
hit 30 in a minute I mean that seems to
be the new gold standard 30 in a minute
that used to be basically on a table
unattainable there he goes he's gotten
it
wow insane
let's see what happens in the 30s will
one of the players manage to get a
strike here or it's looking like they're
doing it flawlessly again and where Rey
really starts pulling away is when both
players hit 40. so so far so good for
mardov but how quickly can he get
through the early 40s
as compared to Rey and I jinxed it there
we go there's that strike
that is unfortunate for Dimitar
second strike that's too much though
that is too much you cannot afford that
against Ray Robson that's it I mean he's
gonna try his best he's got to get at
least to 50. but Ray Robson avoiding
strikes I mean the relief to be able to
solve with no strikes on your plate is
just
incredible oh beautiful tactic there
oh and Bishop D5 at the end to take the
Rook wow
he spots it all
he sees everything as one tilted
streamer once said
foreign
Could Have Been Me
I feel like it's it's my go-to phrase on
nothing's going right race nothing was
going right for Dimitar mardov right now
Ray's going to hit 50 with no strikes
unbelievable I mean look at this it's
mesmerizing every time it happens
it's unbelievable the fact that he's
able to get such a high score wait
what's going on oh my God what a tactic
no I was just mesmerized by the problems
please continue sir
no worries at all we're just gonna
appreciate Ray robson's 53 streak a few
seconds left on the clock he's going to
take the first point of the match and
martov he misses Queen takes G4 track
that's a brilliant Queen sacrifice 55
and Counting how about 56 ladies and
gentlemen for Ray Robson in the first
battle
jeez yesterday he hit 58 will he go
higher today
I'm almost sure he can go higher today
but we'll have to see
you can see how you can get 60. and um
the thing is for Ray I mean at this
point his goal is probably to win every
battle without losing a single
individual battle
and that's a very attainable goal for
him because he just never seems to have
a single bad run
yeah I mean he's not getting a single
strike uh over all of the Apostles he's
solving and it's just insane
and Marta if he did manage to get 56 I
think one or two times yesterday so you
know it's within within his grasp the
problem is doing it on demand in the
format of a battle is so much harder
yeah I mean in puzzle rush you can keep
going if it doesn't go well you can
restart your run but in here if you
restart your own you've already lost the
match
exactly you can't take as many risks
work take C6 Ray again look at his score
he's got 25 26 I mean that's pretty good
in a minute but nothing spectacular but
this is where he starts picking up the
pace or rather staying at the same pace
which is terrifying
indeed now uh Dimitar is on the 32nd one
he gets it he's still ahead on the score
but you need more than that against Ray
Robson and now he's stuck for a moment
and it seems like Ray's catching up
this is a round where dematar got his
first strike in the last battle he has
to avoid strikes at least until he hits
40. let's see so far so good
90 seconds remaining
both players with perfect records
yeah pace for Pace
getting close to 40 now there we go
okay now you can take some more gambles
because you've hit 40 with a clean slate
41 if he goes Rook G2 and rookie two wow
rookie one is bad
King is running away there unfortunate
and you know who else is running away
Ray Robinson
yeah he's on 43 now and doesn't have any
strikes but he's taking his time
absolutely and he he sees dimitro score
he knows he can take his time he'll you
know he'll start solving him instantly
when he gets to the easy problems at 50.
yep and this one both players are uh
having small difficulties with but they
got it right
okay
that one was not difficult wait how is
he a 49 already it's like in the blink
of an island this is an impossible
puzzle Bishop to E4 Rey not seeing it
Bishop B4 forcing King onto a vulnerable
square and he finally gets it
and she's not in a rush
nope he's got no strikes he's up by
three
and there he goes pulling away again
okay that one he he got in about a
millisecond
I have a slight feeling he put a
challenge for himself to not make a
single strike today
I'm I'm speechless I mean there's just
nothing to say
other than the fact that this we are
watching
the greatest player in the world at this
particular type of game and it's always
so impressive to watch the best in the
world it doesn't matter what it is at
it's just you can just sense the other
worldly skill
yeah I mean it must be really
frustrating to be ahead over in the
majority of the of the run and then in
the last like minute 30 seconds suddenly
your opponent is catching up and you're
slowing down because you're not as fast
as your opponent
and it's it's honestly the amount of
hours that Ray has spent on Puzzle
Battle is just Unholy I mean it's it's
probably around the time amount of time
that Michael Jordan spent in uh on the
basketball court it's like
it's just a labor of love for Ray Robson
and it's it shows every minute that he
does that he does it
yeah I mean this is just phenomenal and
once again Dimitar is ahead on the score
but the problem is keeping this score up
keeping this difference up for the
entirety of three minutes that is the
rough part and yeah Rey is just not
taking any risks he's just taking it
easy and making sure that his puzzles
are correct as a matter of fact every
single one of their runs thus far has
followed exactly the same narrative
they're they're keeping Pace with each
other up until right around the high 30s
early 40s that's where demon tar gets a
strike Ray gets up by two or three and
he basically keeps that lead until the
end of the run so let's watch if it
happens again there we go oh there's the
first strike yeah now he now his next
step he's gonna build up a two or three
point lead
there it is well he's got the one point
lead thus far there's the two-point lead
and now he's going to keep it until the
end of the Run
yeah this this almost makes you feel
like three minute like they these
players make it seem like three minute
puzzle rushes are way too long we need
to make it shorter exactly if it was
only a minute and you had a minute to
solve as many problems as you can Ray
would not I mean it's the second and
third minute where his skill really
comes out mm-hmm
you would probably speed up but I would
really love to see if there would be you
know a different situation going on here
oh yeah for sure no he he has the
capacity to solve faster than he's
solving but
like I said he's kept the three-point
lead
no strikes
I think it's either D2 or Rook C4 check
oh he gets it how does he do that
he's just incredible
part of G4 I think so the Roku is a G6
oh no oh he traps the queen incredible
oh he got one wrong
wow breaking news
and does it matter are you still gonna
win
it's his first strike in the first three
battles
second second home it doesn't matter
he's really loose again he's losing his
touch oh no this might be the turning
point no of course not he is 3-0 ahead
everyone he needs to win two more and he
will move on to the next round so the
finals I I just don't understand who can
compete with this and historically only
jimis has been able to give him a run
for his money but the way Jim is
performed in the first round it just
doesn't seem to me that he's going to
come close at this rate but we'll see
it's you can never you never know
you know what I find even funnier than
uh Dania if you take down Rey you have
to take him down another time to get him
eliminated exactly even if you perform
the unattainable
and and the unimaginable and you win you
got to do it again you're absolutely
right that's the double elimination
format
for you
yeah I mean I like the format a lot I
just it's just hard to see uh if anyone
in this field can take down Ray Robson
even in let's leave aside the question
of taking him down in a best of eight
can anybody beat him in a single Puzzle
Battle oh no
because at this rate the answer is no
and there's a strike for demons are oh
God is unlucky for demon turn
it's just so difficult I mean he is so
funny like if we forget about the fact
that he's facing Ray Robinson look at
how much he's doing like how will he
solving the puzzles his accuracy is you
know he's getting 250 he is doing a
great job it's just not enough against
Ray Robson you need much more than this
but his achievement it is amazing but
look at what Ray's doing there he's
taking as long as it takes he took 20
seconds on that puzzle which a lot of
players are not willing to do but Ray
he's got a secret recipe which is no
strikes until you get to the high 40s
because that gives you the Liberty to
solve faster because then you're not
afraid to get not afraid of getting more
strikes and it didn't cost him he's
still up by one but right now they meet
our keeping pace and there's a minute
left so
this one oh a second strike just as I
say that
goodbye
yeah that is it uh for this run
and Rey is just you know keeping the
same Pace he's not in a rush he's doing
great I know where is it it's maybe it's
Rook D1 and then Queen oh that's the
third it doesn't matter it's a third
strike for demon tar yeah and then
there's a Checkmate on the uh with the
bishop on A7 what okay just took the
night Ray knows better that's the rope
and he's gonna rack up his score no he's
no he doesn't even need to rack up his
score he knows this one is over and he's
up four zero
all he needs is to win
one more
incredible wow or no yes yes he needs to
win yeah he needs to win one more well
you can tie it but
um I mean taking down very even in one
round is feels nearly impossible at this
point
it just
no words I have no more words I mean I
think we've said it all I'm obviously
excited to see Rey facing the winner of
jimis against Christopher you in the
finals but
yeah it almost what's scary about this
is it seems that he's almost coasting
like he's like if you really wanted to
he could probably manage you know 55 or
56 in each run if somebody was really
giving him a run for his money
and that's the terrifying thing
yeah exactly he doesn't really need feel
the need to you know perform at his best
he's he's just taking very easy he
doesn't risk anything he's just you know
keeping it up
Okay so
30 30
is the score both players keeping pay 32
in a minute so Ray actually did speed up
334 in a minute what 35 in a minute
oh he's doing it he's doing it he's
gonna get 60 days on yeah he's like you
said you I can't do that yeah take this
you know I can do what Andrew tank does
and then some
her speed though he's also at 36 now
that is not bad at all how did Rey know
which Rook to put on each I mean he just
makes these judgments so quickly I don't
get it
how is it possible
insane
okay this one's tricky I think you just
take the Knight though yeah and run away
what about this one Rook E1 okay okay
two
feels like you must play that but he's
looking for something else
you want that too though there's also
Rockets is correct but what's the
follow-up
is it oh it's just to take the rook and
run with the king oh my gosh that was a
tough One's Gonna struggle with that one
or is he
he gives the check quickly but it's so
hard to decide on Rook A2 and Rook takes
H1 that's gonna take a huge chunk of
time and he got it
and he got okay
so not over yet
this is interesting uh because Rey is
slowing down a little bit
strike here
this is the best chance he's had
obviously by far but here goes Ray again
racking up those points getting himself
to 50. what's the move here demons are
with a strike Ray at 50 I think he's
gonna take this one
unbelievable
yeah this one was the closest but it
doesn't seem that Demeter has any
chances at this point
Reva 52
yeah this is crazy
second strike there but it doesn't
matter anymore because
our finishes on three strikes and Ray
Robson was ahead he goes to the finals
Ray Robson is in the finals that that
phrase has been spoken before every year
and it wasn't even close he wins five to
zero really I mean it was a great
performance by Dimitar was a great run
yesterday but at the end of the day
there's just there's just nothing you
can do I'm gonna keep repeating that
phrase there's just nothing that can be
done about this
yeah this was an epic battle uh it was
really awesome to see demon tarp you
know still try his best uh against Ray
Robinson but it was not enough and Rey
is just showing some insane class here
and I can't wait to see what he has in
store for the next battle
I can't either but we are gonna have
more matches coming your way it's not
just Ray Robson we also have the losers
bracket
um to play out and we will do that after
we take a short break that was an
absolute rubbing by Ray Robson and we
will see if Andrew Tang can come back
from his very painful loss on the other
side of this break here at the puzzles
World Championship we'll be right back
I I wasn't sure if we were supposed to
take a break
January is a special time the Tata steel
super tournament is the Wimbledon of
Chess all of the greatest players in the
last half century and beyond have made
the wintry journey to bike ganzai and
played and won there's a rook of seven
boom Rook takes D4 immediately
played in 2023 the reigning world chess
champion Magnus Carlson returns in the
hopes of winning his ninth Title
One
Tata steel is famous for its tournament
lineup featuring a creative mix of
superstars and super talents that always
guarantees Fighting Chess what a
devastating moment chess.com will be
bringing you the action the drama and
the emotions Live January 13th through
January 29th don't miss history in the
making
oh
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now get the chest clock app right here
almost there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay you bring a clock oh
I left my clock at home dude you idiot I
told you to bring it let's just go get
somebody okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
too
much
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzles world
champion Championship I'm GM Daniel
laraditski alongside me today women's
International Master anime Kazarian and
Amaya Ray Robson but now now it's time
for somebody other than Ray Robson to
step up our other winners bracket
matchup between Christopher you and
Demetrios ledopoulos is about to start I
am so excited for this one Krista for
you was really close to moving to the
losers bracket but in his match uh
against Andy Woodward he barely made it
through uh as well as dimitrios he also
had a tough time against Andrew tang and
he also barely made it so I'm really
looking forward to see who is the better
one in this matchup of course genius has
a slight Advantage he has he's very
experienced but he is showing some signs
of weaknesses so we have to see if
Christopher you is capable of making use
of that and both of them have to step it
up because Christopher you just pulled
off a ridiculous comeback against Andy
Woodward he was down four puzzles to one
with his back against the wall he wins
the next three puzzles on demand and
gets the higher total score so that kind
of stuff Ain't Gonna Fly against
Demetrius and From demetrius's
perspective he made so many mistakes in
the first 10 puzzles very
uncharacteristic I don't know if it was
a computer thing or if it was a mouse
thing or if it was a nurse thing but
whatever it is he needs to figure it out
and he needs to have a much cleaner run
the first 30 puzzles like we're used to
seeing from him
absolutely so let's find out uh we're
about to start with the next match
um again they are playing at Best of
eight so they're playing puzzle battles
and once again everyone if there is a
tie between the players it depends
um so basically how it goes every single
puzzle Rush Puzzle Battle
um if one player gets three strikes the
other player can claim the win if there
is a tight score so that's why it may be
confusing at times if you see they have
the same score but one of the players
wins the run it might be confusing at
times but this has to do with the fact
that one of the players has run out of
strikes three strikes that's it the
other one can clean the win if they have
a tight score or higher so yeah you
gotta be really careful with those
strikes you do and the overall score
matters only in the event of a 4-4 tie
in that case the player who has gotten
more overall points across all eight
runs uh wins the match so okay I think
we've got the logistics squared away we
are ready to start uh the next match
between Demetrius lidopolis and
Christopher you
and we'll see I mean Demetrios he's
obviously not the strongest OTB player
he's the weakest OTB player in the field
but it doesn't matter right Puzzle
Battle it's a different game it's all
about tactics it's all about the amount
of hours that you put in and in that
regard he can compete with anybody
exactly I mean he has spent so much time
in puzzle rushes he is pretty much the
only one that has been able to compete
versus Ray Robson and that goes to show
the amount of time he has spent has been
very much worth it but is he able to
take down Ray Robinson this time first
he's in this match but as you guys know
we do have a double elimination bracket
if you lose one match you still have a
chance to come back and win the whole
event which makes this event so exciting
it really does you get another chance
and I love double elimination I think
it's very fair I think it gives
everybody you know it's a little bit
less Draconian than single elimination
uh but I I see a little grumbling in the
chat about the fact that you know in the
event of a tight score the player with
more strikes loses that to me makes
actual perfect sense logically because
you you should get punished for getting
more wrong than your opponent on the
contrary if you got the same score and
you got more puzzles right you got less
wrong that is then you should be
rewarded for it right so you should be
rewarded not only for your overall score
but also for your accuracy and I think
it's an elegant way uh to give the
player with a higher accuracy a little
bit of a boost
exactly I fully agree with you Dania you
have to be rewarded for not making
mistakes and that's also why we saw Ray
Robson not going for those strikes and
taking it very easy and Daya I see that
the players just started their first run
they have indeed and will be bringing
you that very shortly it'll be
Christopher you
against Demetrius ladopoulos
and uh
the players are off we'll uh keep you uh
a prize of the scores thus far they're
just sort of moving right along both of
them getting all of them right
yeah we'll get to it in a moment
um
there we go
go we got it up and it's 22-22 with 45
seconds past neither player getting any
wrong here we go
wow they are very close uh on the score
both 25 now Christopher you slightly
faster than uh dimitrios but can he keep
it up endometrios this time oh and this
time it's Krista for you the early
strike and dimitrios he fixed his
problem will Christopher you fix his
Demetrius with a clean record through
the first 30 puzzles that's exactly what
he needs to do and this is more like the
Demetrius that we're used to
yep very accurate but he's not taking
some time okay you solved the puzzle but
it took some time of him
and Rook takes E1 that's an easy mate
for Christopher you both sides at 36
right now one strike is not the end of
the world when you hit two and it's
under 40 that's when you're kind of done
for Ah that's the worst having two
strikes you know that one more strike
it's over and especially in those
matches the scores are so close you
can't sit and wait and hope that uh your
opponent is not going to make it he he
will
yeah and
Demetrius is still clean with a minute
left he's got 44.
I honestly think if he hits an average
of 50 that might be enough to pull it
off let's see if Christopher can speed
up just a little bit here while
preserving only one strike he's had that
three-point deficit for most of the
final minute
good job by Christopher keeping his
composure
keeping it close but is it close enough
I don't think so 50 for Demetrios yeah
against dimitrios I mean he's on 49 now
50. 30 seconds left on the clock maybe
again some other player Christopher you
could have a chance but but against
dimitrios he knows those puzzles in the
50s he's Off to the Races there's 54 and
it's just like it's the same with Rey
like once these they hit the 50s they're
just 55 he might actually have the
highest score today wow so you heard us
he says you want to see a better gymnast
well here you go 56.
and tonight for the highest total today
oh my god wow what an impressive run by
dimitrios
incredible incredible run he wins by
nine
but that's only the first battle and if
you're Christopher you're really hoping
for an early mistake from gymnast that
seems to be the big difference between
the gym as we saw in the first few
matches against Andrew and the gym as we
just saw can he stay clean in the first
minute
yeah that is really really important but
as it is looking like genius is very
very uh you know taken easy and he is
very accurate
10 10 now players are moving up very
fast at the very beginning let's see if
they can still hit 30 in a minute
watching let's see if they can hit 30
indeed
it does look like at least one of them
probably even both of them will
yep
20 okay
well Christopher you but you know going
really fast
yeah he's keeping Pace thus far but so
is jimus
mm-hmm
okay
me six now
almost at 30 but not just yet in one
minute not yet
wow they're and they're they're again
solving so quickly that you know the
server doesn't even keep up with the
speed of their Solutions 30 for both now
all right but this is where players like
Jemison race start to break away
yeah and we were shown in the future
chat that dimitrios has a puzzle rating
of
4267 and that goes to the show he has
practiced all of those difficult puzzles
he knows them pretty much by heart you
could almost say
well I I I really do think that the Rey
and gymnast they know almost all of the
puzzles from 50 onwards by heart I mean
there's no way otherwise to solve them
and it's it's not uh I don't mean this
in any detrimental way it's a product of
you know hundreds of hours of
of uh solving and resolving those
puzzles but two strikes now for Jim is
and he's really struggling in the 40s
Christopher is pulling away
what is a very tough situation for
Demetrius being on two strikes and also
down on the score
I don't know what the move is there I
think it's nice to see six
but I'm not sure and he's still stuck
and finally 64.
oh and what's the second move I don't
know
oh it's one six that was so hard but
Christopher now with two strikes of his
own
Dimitri's gotta go he's got 30 seconds
to catch up plenty of time
but Christopher is stuck now on the on
the 50s one
mm-hmm
is
I think A3 A3 just pushed the pawn oh
he's two C's taking too long he's gotten
it though
three strikes are kissing for you 15
seconds four demons can he oh my God he
needs to get to 51. to the wire he needs
to get this one quickly he's not seeing
it he doesn't see it oh my God
Christopher you struggling as well can
he get it no no he
does oh my gosh and Christopher pulls
out the Second Battle are you kidding me
wow are you kidding me
insane down to the wire and now we have
a tight match one to one
one to one is the score and this is what
Christopher needs he needs to score 51
52 every time Jim as he tried his best
but he just took a little bit too long
and those early two strikes by Jim is in
the early 40s that's what really cost
him
yeah he was doing a fantastic job in the
final puzzles but it was not enough he
was simply few seconds too short to Win
It
yeah yeah it just wasn't quite enough
and if he if he had three yeah three
more seconds is really all he would yeah
and he would have won because he would
have had only two strikes to
Christopher's three yep
no the players are again around 20 no
strikes
seems like they're going much faster
here
and okay
easier now
okay oh it's this one though he's six
can't make it up
there's 30 in a minute
that's the target
Christmas
and you can see the speed of what he's
how he's uh making the moves it's
actually awesome to have this view you
know because typically you don't see the
player's mouths or how the player is
moving the pieces around and now you can
see live with his finger on the iPad
yeah you can you could you have the
proof of it happening and there's a
strike for Christopher we keep talking
about him unfortunately he gets one
wrong and this gives Jim us a big chance
yeah one minute and 20 seconds left on
the clock second strive for Krista for
you that is a very costly one
this might be the end but there's a
strike for jimis and again he's just
struggling through the early 40s I mean
this is uncharacteristic
yep
but he is uh taking the lead now with
42.
is Christopher used able to catch up
here I mean he is on 41 but two strikes
is making his life very difficult in
this run
game there that Christopher navigated
successfully it is making his life
difficult but he's still he's taking
gambles that's what you got to do for
Christopher you just you have to take
risks and stay afloat here but Demetrios
is merciless as he builds it up to 50.
Madness and it was this puzzle that
Christopher you is on that Demetrius
sold so quickly whereas Christopher is
taking his time there and he needs to
speed up now
and he is speeding up he's gotten 48
he's very close to catching up at
Demetrios with a big one there to get
50. that's the golden score
and oh a second he made some Demetrius
but Christopher mistake no Christopher's
not gonna get stuck no he doesn't have
time no
no
um
he just needed to be a little bit faster
on that 49th puzzle and that would have
given him just enough time
Madness Demetrios taking the lead now to
one but this match is anyone's game I
mean both players have are really close
on the scores in the last two runs and
yeah anything can honestly happen here
this is the closest Puzzle Battle we
have seen by I mean every run is
literally coming down the last puzzle
yeah it's it's insane
yeah now the players are speeding up in
the first few puzzles we see that
Christopher who's ahead a few puzzles so
that might give him some Advantage but
at the same time the material is
catching up here and you know you gotta
have a bigger advantage to feel
comfortable against Demetrius
but I it does seem to me that
Christopher is a little bit faster in
the first minute he he does have that
two three-point lead most of the time
it's just both players I think the key
for them is to avoid strikes on let's
say puzzles 30 to 45 they can get to 40
or 45 with no strikes
right now Christopher is doing a
phenomenal job of it can he continue his
clean streak
take the queen I don't know what the
move is there
that's Demetrios ketchup
what's the move it's just oh it's just
takes in C5 wow okay
it did not look exactly
no
it wasn't Bishop takes B5
oh first try for crystal for you again
but he's still ahead on the score
by one but Demetrios catches up
already Tuna from Christopher this is
going to be another barn burner they are
literally neck and neck in the second
strike for Christopher that will cost
him
oh man and still clean see Demetrios
gets the 45 with a minute left and he is
clean this is gonna be almost impossible
for Christopher yeah one minute left on
the match on the game uh clock heater uh
for this run and Christopher you tied up
the score now but is it enough two
strikes they stay there they don't go
away
47 47 48 now for Demetrios he's speeding
up a little bit
this is cheap I feel like I'm running a
marathon
and I'm not even solving 49.49
Christopher is somehow keeping Pace he's
got 50.
and 51 for Demetrius it's 51-51 20
seconds left 251.
53-51 but Christopher is not to be
outdone here's a strike for Demetrios
can he get to 53 yes he can oh it's time
even if Christopher would have gotten it
as Demetrius gets up to 55 he would have
still lost because Demetrios had less
strikes
that is unfortunate for Christopher you
but Jim is now taking the lead uh making
the Gap bigger and is leading
um 3-1 now
what a backbreaker to score 53 and what
a job by Christopher you had two strikes
early and he was like carrying an
elephant behind him and he still managed
to put together his highest score of
this battle but it just is not enough
when Demetrios is in you know his best
puzzle form
yeah I mean look at the speed of the
players and you know Christopher is
playing really well and it's very fast
but it is not enough against Jimmy's I
mean dimitrios is so experienced and he
knows how to deal with those tougher
puzzles
exactly he does indeed and
right now it's up to
Kristen for you to avoid losing if he
loses this one then he ends up in the
same spot
that he was against Andy Woodward down
41 except something tells me jimus is
not going to give that lead away
yeah that is not very characteristic of
Jimmy's
while he's very experienced and uh yeah
he's uh he's he's keeping the pace up I
mean he's 35 now still a little bit
behind the crystal for you but we know
his strength that comes out in the 40s
and 50s Christopher hits the target 40
without a strike in fact both of them do
there was a bishop under promotion there
42 shoot now without a strike for both
players
Bishop C6 and E5 very cleanly delivered
by Christopher there's the first strike
by James and there's one by Christopher
oh both on one strike no and he got the
same one wrong Christopher might be
pulling away here
oh my goodness jimus is shocked here at
44. two strikes as well for Christopher
you oh my gosh this one's gonna be who
can preserve their nerves 47 but
Christopher is a big lead here or does
he
oh jimus he got it for 47. Christopher
and they've got an entire minute they
got plenty of time here they don't have
to rush at all
but Demetrios catches up
oh my life I know
51 Christopher keeps going fast so is
Jim is there's 52 can he get it Rook a
G1 check no it's Knight takes E3 oh
that's easy to miss goodness but James
is on top
he doesn't miss finds it Rook 81 what a
move both of them fight it it's 53
apiece
25 seconds left and they are 53 two
strikes who is going to make the first
mistake here neither one wanting to take
too many gambles both of them got it
wrong
it's time to draw and they got the wrong
move they got two different moves and
both of them were wrong
oh wow what does this mean for the score
because it was three to one now we have
a tie I believe we are in for another
run
we are in for another run so the score
right now
he's three and a half
to
um one and a half which means that if
Demetrius lodopoulos wins this run he
wins the entire contest because it's
first to four and a half or five right
best of eight so Christopher with his
back against the wall in an early strike
this is the Demetrius we saw against
Andrew
oh this is not looking good for
Demetrius but there's only one strike
it's only one strike but this can cost
him now he needs to be a little bit more
careful a little bit more conservative
in how he solves and that's gonna let
Christopher really open up that five six
point lead that he's gonna try to
preserve and there's a second strike
total tilt total tilt for jimmus he's
giving this one away
he is down six points on the scoreboard
he's on two strikes this is not looking
good for dimitrios
and right now for Demetrios he needs to
try to get as high of a score as he can
even if he won't win this run remember
that and he actually might because
Christopher just had a strike
in the event of a tie it's all about who
has the highest cumulative score so you
do not want to have like a 20-point run
in there
I just witnessed a 36 in one minute
Christopher you
and right now on Christopher he loses
his discipline he needed to get a
hundred in the event of a tie that was a
big big Miss there for Christopher he
could have gotten and racked up his
overall score
yeah but now the total score is three uh
difference uh between the players and we
continue with the next one once again if
Demetrius wins this one it is over he
will move on to the next round he's got
two more chances who is gonna face Ray
Robson in the finals and here's the
thing
I mean Demetrios with two early strikes
in that last run he has to avoid those
sloppy mistakes at the start
has to avoid them
Christopher you on godspeed here look at
him 18.
he's once again
it's your fault totally oh no and that
earlier that's honestly been the
downfall for both of these players when
they lose it's it's that early strike
that one it just creates the seed of
uncertainty in your mind and you start
solving slower
you cannot afford a second strike
Christopher is back against the wall but
still ahead so far in this battle
still ahead he's solving those puzzles
super super fast faster than dimitrios
but he needs to keep up this pace and
that is the difficult part
[Music]
Demetrius getting to 32 without a strike
now 33 without a strike
[Music]
wow King on e4 getting checkmated crazy
Christopher has managed to continue
solving very quickly
but he's a little bit stumped there
and he navigates his way to 39 only one
strike
but dimitrios has gotten to the Target
score and kept it clean no he doesn't I
jinxed him he's got two strikes and he's
doing it again he just starts tilting
instantly oh my great a second
I'm 44. he's ahead three points one
minute left on the clock second strike
for Chris over you as well oh my God and
here we go both players one more mistake
and they lose it's continuous tie it yes
he can it's 44 a piece and Christopher
is stuck he missed it that's it he
should claim the win
good awareness By Demetrios knowing well
actually a draw would not have won this
battle so he knows to claim the win he
is in the finals against Ray Robson and
Christopher you will have to make it
work in the losers bracket
wow what a match this was Christopher
you played phenomenal Chaz here
phenomenal puzzle runs here that was an
insanely close battle it came all the
way down to the wire in every in almost
every single battle over there but in
the end it was Demetrios taking down
Christopher you
the two favorites are going to face each
other in the final it'll be Rey against
gymnast but first we're gonna watch some
losers bracket action to see who can
climb all the way back after an initial
disappointment you're watching the
puzzles World Championship we'll be back
with more action on the other side of
this break
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
do you
[Music]
think
hi
[Music]
foreign
hi
[Music]
hello
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the puzzle World
Championship where we are observing a
masterful display by of course none
other than Ray Robson who has been now
through two stages and made his way into
the final where he will be facing the
one and only gymnast and I'm
commentating with the one and only
women's International master anamaya
anmaya I mean I remember when I was
watching the Olympics in 2012 the coach
of the Nigerian basketball team he set a
very famous phrase there are three
basketball teams uh that you need to be
careful about the United States the USA
and the US well there are three players
so we need to be careful of in The
Puzzle Battle Grand Master Ray Robson
Ray and Robson
very well said Donya indeed Ray Robson
has won all puzzle championships so far
he will be facing his I mean dimitrios
uh laude pulos he is very very strong
and very close to Ray Robson but is it
enough will it be enough for today I am
not so sure Ray Robson has shown insane
performance and Demetrios has also shown
grade scores today but is it enough
against three reps and we will have to
see Diane
we will have to find out and gymnast is
going to have to bring his absolute and
only a game to every single battle
because Ray Robson not only is he who he
is but it almost seems like today he's
in especially good form or maybe I'm
just under you know the spell I don't
know
I mean he's barely
here under where he had
because his opponent had three strikes
already it didn't matter anymore he is
so he's playing he's solving them so
perfectly he doesn't make any mistakes
it is unreal
no and really it's been fascinating to
observe Rey's philosophy in action his
philosophy States uh see himself has put
in interviews that you your top priority
should be to go without strikes until at
least 40 45 and he has observed that
280. will he be able to reproduce that
philosophy against jimus this is going
to be his hardest test yet
absolutely and we are now in the final
however the loser the you know the
person that that loses this I'm not
moves on to lose record I really hate
calling someone that loses a game a
loser doesn't really feel fitting but
you move on to the losers bracket and
you still have a chance to win uh but I
do not like the thought of having to
play Ray Robson twice
not either but that's what somebody is
going to have to do here we go and they
are off this is based of eight ladies
and gentlemen so the first player who
wins five individual individual puzzle
battles or four and a half in the event
of a tie wins and qualifies to the Grand
Final here we go
all right I mean wait they're playing
really fast okay 18 19.
20 and 30 seconds okay this is really
fast Dania
and James's only problem thus far has
been his lack of consistency and
stability the good runs jimis has gotten
56 that's the highest score gotten today
also by Ray but the lack of consistency
is going to kill you right because you
can't afford to give up two or three of
these rushes to Ray Robinson
yeah and currently Demetrius is ahead
31 now but can he keep it up for the
rest of the Run only one minute has
passed now
and so far so good for both players a
clean record and check me with H5 95 and
queen F7 and Knight G6
and Bishop B5
flawlessly executed by Rey
and he actually takes his time usually
I've noticed that he's a little bit
slower in the initial battles as he gets
his feet under him
and then at some point he just kind of
just takes off
yeah but James
gets to 40 can he get to 40 without a
striker will I Jinx him again no I'm not
no not this time Dania
now it's your turn oh no don't put the
pressure on me
I'm gonna orchestrate the Jinx James is
going to get
two more without a strike
oh there's one okay all right okay okay
the prophet that it's the work again
you can't Jinx on demand that's what I'm
learning look at you because he's up by
four ready to put Ray needs to step it
up here in the last 45 seconds plenty of
time for Rey but Jim is
48 now he's got 49 and he's gotten to
his biggest specialty
But Here Comes Ryan
and Rey is catching up with 48. can he
get to 49 he needs to be quick here
50 from jimus oh this is gonna be close
one point difference oh this is getting
really close 20 seconds left now
Jim is continuing to put the pressure on
Ray he's got 51 but no strikes from Ray
that could decide the outcome here both
on 51 Ray knows this one and Jim is with
the second strike race Gotta Go Gotta Go
Gotta Go
he's got it 52. can we get to 53. Jim is
he's got to move he doesn't make it Ray
wins oh my goodness the time right now
and Jimmy's had more strikes
wow Jim is loses the first battle by the
skin and the hair on his chinny chin
chin oh my God
that was an intense battle and the score
they go again for their doing 52 is not
that high they can do they can do much
better but yeah a really Tense one
Ray just I I mean who am I to criticize
Raya he is of course he is his record is
unimpeachable but insofar as what one
can offer uh what Rey would probably
tell himself it's that he was just a
little bit too casual I think in the
first 90 seconds he was he's not usually
the fastest but he's got to try to get
to 40 I think in in 90 seconds that
should be his goal
but this guy's unbeatable like what do
you have to do to be right it's like
insane yeah on demand that is just you
know nearly impossible let's see if he
can make it happen he's currently GMS is
currently on 21 but he's not hitting the
30 in a minute and that is slightly
concerning
so let's see 27 27 smothered me my
favorite
hey
and you take the Rook have you ever
smothered mated somebody in an OTB game
um it wasn't I was very young it was a
simul and I yeah yeah but it was a slime
it didn't really count for anything
it was just Pride you know but it was
pretty cool did you I've only done it
once when I was 1700 I still have the
game I was playing a like a a beginner
in round one of a tournament and I won a
queen and I could like smell it from a
mile away so I took like six moves to
set it up so it wasn't like the most
glamorous smothered me but I I made it
happen eventually he didn't know it a
strike there by jimis oh and the problem
with gymnast is he does tilt he does
tilt
and let's see if you can avoid that
second strike that's the Dreadful one
yeah they're now in the 40s oh there you
go second strike for Jim is
indeed and Rey is just coasting right
now with no mistakes and 44 points
and this is Rook A4 and queen takes A7
and queen A8 and chiseling his way into
Black's position but Jim is continuing
to keep pace for the time being
46 he's still ahead but two strikes that
is a deal breaker here that is going to
make things very difficult and now it's
tight even
48 for gemis it's gonna be close again
this is far from over unless he gets a
third strike right now and Jim is stuck
giving Ray a chance to get ahead 50. oh
man here goes Ray Robson he's in his
element He knows this one
and Jim is still stuck
oh my God that was an awesome difference
that was an impossible one Rey is
pulling away that's it that is it
three strikes now
and array just like casually getting to
53. and it's too nil
very impressive score once again
two nil I mean James is putting up such
an amazing fight but it's not enough
he's getting those strikes too easily
um early on uh relatively early on and
that is hurting his chances
this is James's best performance of the
match it's just not good enough for Mr
Robson
yeah and that hurts that hurts a lot
and Jimmy's is going to be awaiting the
winner
of the first couple games in the losers
bracket so he will get another chance
most probably I mean we're talking about
it as if he's already lost I'm going to
be honest it certainly feels that way it
feels it feels like Rey is incapable of
losing a single battle
I mean much less an entire contest yeah
you could almost say that uh Ray Robson
is the mittens of puzzle Rush
unbeatable good speaking of unbeatable
there's another early strike for jimmus
I
and unfortunately he has often followed
it with a second strike in the next five
six puzzles
can he avoid it
31 array 32 for Rey very close on the
scores but district oh where he gets
destroyed and a very uncharacteristic
strike I mean this is as rare as it gets
and both players now
at exactly the same Pace this is a
chance for gymnast this is a big chance
38 now for both 39 can they get to Fort
how do you solve this one oh my God
there's a fork there I wouldn't solve it
in 30 minutes
not in 30 seconds
peas are just flying over the board
I mean I'm not even registering the
position at this one and they're already
solving it
so 45 for Jim it's 46 for Jim is he has
taken off since that first strike But
Here Comes Ray Robson he's like no no no
I got this under control I'm chilling
and it they're tied again
and Jim is a little bit stumped there
but he got it
Queen takes f8 and then back to D6 is
the game take that Knight 48-48.
over there
oh E5 no he's got to know this one E5
Queen D5 are you kidding me
oh and Ray knows what's next
did you have to take on G7 what was that
I think it's Rook D1
oh man
Jim is with two strikes he doesn't care
but Ray says I care
goes Ray he's gonna get 53. what is this
54 coming in
oh no he's pulling away this might be
his biggest run of this evening
and jimmis is done three strikes three
strikes yes 55. can he get to 56 that's
his highest score of the day
yes
Ray Robson today
this is what I feel like when I'm
playing Magnus and Blitz like this is
the feeling you get like no matter what
you do or how many ideas you find or how
many puzzles you get right in this case
it's just not going to be enough he's
always going to get more than you
three nil
can he complete the whitewashing here
yeah so in case of a four zero score Ray
only needs it would draw or a win so
yeah draws are really difficult in this
format but we saw it is possible it is
achievable it is somehow achievable
and once again dimitrios is faster in
those early puzzles
but he slows down
um at some point where Rey is just going
at it again and again and again
yeah it's it's he's the Mike Tyson the
the
I don't know the Lionel Messi of puzzle
Rush Puzzle Battle
and I remember that there was a great
deal of speculation
uh perhaps some of the old-timers in
chat will remember as to who spicy
caterpillar was that of course is a race
just.com account name now it's public
but there was a point at which he was
getting crazy scores in puzzle rush and
nobody knew who it was there was tons of
speculation Agnes
Bobby Fischer's ghost you know and then
eventually it was revealed now of course
we know it can be nobody other than Rey
wow that that's pretty crazy it reminds
me of the times also where uh there was
another puzzle solver cascus a fellow
Dutch uh young man
um it it is unfortunate to see he's not
participating in this event because I
think he could put a great challenge up
for Ray Robson
you most certainly could he even got a
hundred I think famously on a survival
yeah or a five minute round and by the
way two strikes are Genesis losing
control here completely
but uh yeah this is not looking good for
the Demetrius
yep he's those three three strikes
that's it that's it now Rey if he really
wants to do this as clinically as
possible he should try to get as many as
he can
in the off chance that somehow Jamis
wins all of the other Pub battles he's
still probably not gonna make it because
Rey is going to rack up this score so
much that he's going to be in La La Land
by the time you blink
yeah I mean look at this 47 now
it is looking very tough to beat his
highest today of 56. that is uh looking
very far away he's definitely gonna
manage 50 and probably a lot more
because this is where he just starts
solving instantly
to what is this what are these moves
there should be five check I guess oh my
God
Bishop takes G2
and then I don't see it Queen F2 really
Riley and Rook takes you two he's got
53. there's 54. can he manage 55 no 54
what a failure only gets 54.
yeah too bad too bad
he is just
this is just ridiculous and he's gonna
put jimus out of his misery I think in
the next run
yeah and Ray Robson still hasn't lost
the one Puzzle Battle today insane
I think I mean after this year I I don't
know if
I don't know if anybody will ever come
along who's a better puzzle battler than
Ray Robson I think this might be
greatest of not just currently but
really of all time for all of eternity
yeah it's just insane and it's super
inspiring as well but
you have to take you to spend a lot of
time to catch up with Ray Robson he has
spent so much time into puzzle rushes
and all of those puzzles on chess.com
it's not easy to catch up with him
well Malcolm gladwell's famous 10 000
hour rule I think it definitely applies
to Puzzle Battle and yeah I think 10 000
hours probably the minimum that Ray has
spent it's probably about double that
but uh the level of Mastery that he has
achieved
is is honestly unparalleled
meanwhile Demetrius is ahead Five Points
here so he's looking good in this run at
least he is indeed
can you avoid the strikes that have
plagued him in the late 30s
almost feels like we're talking about an
H here rather than yeah the late 30s
yeah oh no
he's almost at 40. okay dimitrios at 40
now can he keep it up
and we got
say my name Rook H3 maybe just toss the
queen away and then Queen H6 Bishop
Bishop F1
yes
oh
not a question is will Rey solve it
instead we got sraven in the chat with
an excellent performance yesterday
almost qualified welcome to saravan
renjith
okay Knight C4 Bishop F4 is
easy Eric there and Knight A4 oh they're
treating night move no problem for Rey
excuse me though yeah yeah he's gonna
get to 50 I think with only one strike
this is a chance here Jim is not going
gentle into that good night he's got 50.
but here goes Ray
you know it comes Ray bit 49. and he's
got 50. caught up 51.
yes he can
53. oh my gosh and jimus is keeping Pace
they're on the same puzzle
what's the move here is it DC or D2 it's
D2 and he got it wow and James did as
well oh my gosh it's down to the wire
folks
oh Ray gets a strike oh I should just
dropped that one wrong too no it's open
strike 54. she just needs to get 55 man
he got him but Ray got 56.
wow again
and it would not have mattered even if
Rey didn't get that 56th one he would
have still won because a draw would have
been enough to propel him forward but
still he keeps his perfect streak alive
what a finale an am I this is
the greatest Puzzle Battle display we
have ever seen no question about it yes
this was an amazing final and guess what
we might see this final once again
because Ray Robson is moving on to the
Grand Final and dimitrios is moving to
the losers bracket but he still has a
chance I'm back to the Grand Final
he does indeed he will have to climb
through the loser's bracket and he will
first and foremost have to face uh of
course uh the winner of Dimitar mardov
against Christopher you which we will be
watching on the other side of this break
you're watching the puzzles World
Championship don't go anywhere we will
have more Ray Robson and more Demetrios
and more Krista for you on the other
side of this short break
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow Test
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
foreign
check it out
[Music]
three two one
check it out
[Music]
foreign
hi
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
puzzles World Championship as we review
you the bracket after three hours of
action here on the final day it is no
surprise that Ray Robson has already
made it into the grand finals he will be
facing the winner of the losers bracket
the losers bracket will feature
Christopher you against Dimitar mardov
the winner of that match will face
Demetrius ladopoulos to determine who
can rematch Ray Robson for the grand
final women's International Master Ana
Maya Kazarian is commentating alongside
me today it's been non-stop
entertainment and we have seen some
absolutely phenomenal puzzle solving
displays as we expected to see
absolutely Daya this event is so
exciting we know that Ray Robson is the
ultimate boss in this total tournament
however we still have a lot of matches
that we are going to expect day today we
are going to see Crystal for you taking
on Dimitar mardov this match is going to
be a very close one I'm really looking
forward to this one on there is no real
favorite in my opinion both players are
very strong in puzzle Ranch they've
proven themselves and I can't wait to
see who will move on to face dimitrios
both of them are so impressive I'm
obviously biased I'm a big Christopher
you fan he did he is from my Aries from
the the San Francisco Bay area and uh I
really watched him grow from you know a
tiny kid who whose Talent was obvious
immediately like you had one lesson with
them and it was just no pun intended and
it was obvious that he was going to be
something special and he has grown into
something special phenomenal opening
preparation he's also a study composer
he actually composes his own studies and
has won awards and obviously a
phenomenal puzzle solver in his own
right but just hasn't been quite enough
thus far to unseat Ray Robson can he
make his way back to faze jimis
well yeah it's our mardov stands in his
way
yeah and both players moved on to the
second uh round winning their first
round but then lost their games unless
their matches
um against Ray Robson and Demetrios
moved on to the losers bracket and got
all the way here now can they make it to
the next one who will make it to the
next round we will find out very shortly
because the winner will be facing
Demetrius lado pulos and after that we
will have in the Grand Final Ray Robson
the final boss
and dimitrovardov did defeat Andrew Tang
Christopher you defeated Frederick
savane in the first round of the losers
bracket which uh we didn't watch but
obviously we had our our hands full with
a guy named Ray Robson
and uh Demetrios is gonna you know chill
out take a seat and uh enjoy watching
Christopher and Dimitar go after each
other to determine who he's going to
play now Christopher I think has been a
little bit more consistent than demons
are demons are much like gymnast I think
has to avoid those early strikes I'm
less worried about that on Christopher's
behalf but you know we've had a
surprisingly few bad runs I don't think
we've had any runs by anybody really
under 40 maybe one or two
yeah we only had a couple honestly uh
you would expect that in a format like
uh puzzle battles you may see some
um you know uh tough runs here and there
we all know that we all have experience
that we you know I sometimes have my
first few puzzles wrong it happens you
start a new one but here in Puzzle
Battle you have to be very precise from
start to finish every single run because
your opponent does the same and does not
forgive you for that one mistake you
made in the early ones
I might be uh out of line here uh or
overstating the case but I honestly feel
like everybody has gotten better at
Puzzle Battle uh compared to last year
like I remember seeing a lot of tilt
runs last year where you get one wrong
at the start and then you just get two
more rung pretty quickly we're seeing
just incredible consistency from
everybody we are seeing a fair share of
early strikes although not that many but
even the players who strike early it's
like they keep their composure and they
still have managed to put through a
couple 50 plus Point runs so a really
impressive consistency for both player
for everybody player involved
absolutely and for those who are just
tuning in we are in the puzzles world
championship and this format is a puzzle
battle knockout so the players are
facing each other in three minute puzzle
Rush runs and the one that has the
highest score in the specific run gets a
score on the scoreboard and we're not
gonna lose this bracket in the winners
bracket it was best of eight however
Tanya in the losers bracket it is best
of four so less runs so that makes makes
it even harder because you have to be
even more precise than before
no margin for error if you lose two
battles you whoa
that was a earthquake like shaking sorry
I think that was a oh gosh
something like the ground just shook
under me
um I think it was a truck but anyways um
my heart is like beating on it just yeah
you're absolutely right if you lose two
battles let me try that again uh you're
basically busted I mean you can
obviously come back with a two battle
win and then we remind you this is going
to be very pertinent in the event of a
2-2 tie the player with the highest
cumulative score total score wins the
battle so this is gonna be important I
think we are going to get a tie and
let's get the show on the road we got
Christopher you and Dimitar mardov they
are on camera there and uh the match
should begin momentarily
yeah the match should start soon Demeter
martov seems to be ready but Christopher
you not just yet so we have to wait a
couple of moments uh until he's back but
we should start the match very soon I'm
so excited to see how they will play as
it is best of four so the match could
already end after three runs
um and yeah the players have to be very
precise this time I mean we saw in the
best of Aid you still have some you know
room for mistakes and uh losing one run
is not a big deal but here it is it
counts for a lot so you have to be very
precise
indeed and just a quick review of the
matches in the losers bracket uh that we
didn't see we saw Christopher you
defeating Frederick savane by a pretty
wide margin uh and we also saw dimitro
martov defeating Andrew Tang which is a
match that kind of flew under the radar
but Andrew Tang has been incredibly
impressive in the puzzles World
Championship so unfortunately his run
comes to an end of the hands uh first of
Andy Woodward and then of Dimitra or
sorry he beat Andy Woodward in the first
round of the losers bracket and then
lost at the hands of dimitro martov so
Andrew Tang came that close to beating
jimus let's not forget that that's how
close he came unfortunately it wasn't
meant to be
yeah I mean we all remember yesterday's
um puzzle Rush runs where Andrew Tang
was about to get eliminated and in his
final run he could not start another one
it was his very last one he managed to
make it through to today's uh event so
he was disclosed to be in what is the
final pretty much he was doing an
excellent job today as well but it was
just not enough
it was not enough and Christopher taking
his sweet time to get ready my seatbelt
is fast and I am ready to watch some
Puzzle Battle let's go demits armardov
there on the right side you can see him
uh he's probably on a computer and there
we go we are off this is a best of four
ladies and gentlemen it's not best of
eight it is best of four Christopher
make a move
oh he's what is he doing what's he doing
he's looking up confused it seems he's
like he's refreshing the tab
he's refreshing the tab and oh that's
right I think you need to be on the
laptop that's why I need to be on a
laptop I don't I don't get this little
iPad Thing by Christopher to be honest I
I'm I'm not a fan of it I I'm impressed
with it but now you're paying the price
for it and they're gonna have to restart
oh man
and the worst part for me at least when
I saw him solve it on the iPad he is
using the browser on the iPad he's not
even using the app he's using the
browser so that it feels a little
unreliable what is going on okay the
aborted the Run
okay they're gonna have to refresh and
start a new run
and there they go and then okay
Christopher has functionality this time
he does but I guess whatever works for
him he's always done it from an iPad
historically so you know I respect that
but nonetheless I think all things held
equal
playing on a computer is just more
reliable here we go okay
so far so good for both players
yeah they're very fast in the beginning
no mistakes
can they hit 30 in one minute is the
question every single time
22-22
nice yeah I'm picking up the night
25-25
we're not there you
I was gonna I was gonna make a joke but
I'll make it I guess next run I know the
score after 1919 I was gonna tell you
I'm having a hard time seeing the score
what is it supposed to say 2020.
unfortunately unfortunately Christopher
you was has been ahead for most of this
run but here goes mardov
stuck on rookie eight
oh that's tough one it feels like you
have to play 93.4 oh the move was the
move was H6 there Christopher with a
really sloppy move
okay
and mardov does it he he finds to H6 and
gets this puzzle correct
he does indeed and you know what else
you can do sometimes when you feel your
opponent you hear your opponent getting
it wrong you actually know that you
should spend a little bit longer this is
a pretty well-known hack where you
actually have to use that as information
to tell you that there's a tempting move
that you should avoid yeah yeah that's
uh that's a very nice uh in type of
information that you can use indeed in
your favor
mardov is free of strikes but down on
the score so I think the situation is
about even right now he has avoided
strikes at 44.
oh but is mardov able to keep up with
Krista for is a question because
Christopher is on a roll here 47 now
however he got stuck on this one okay he
solved it in the end
yes he did 48-47 they are going neck and
neck oh
yeah exactly
shaking voice Emoji 50 by Christopher
with only one strike this is an amazing
run for both of them
can mardov get that 50th one second
strike for Christopher
he can get even the next one righty has
got three attempts now Marta's gonna win
this one that's it you can claim the win
but I wouldn't claim the win I would try
no not yet because he's got two strikes
he doesn't have any strikes even
well I'm saying he has two strikes to
expect before he claims to win and he's
gonna get a nice little 52. he's gonna
get 53 for Dimitar mardov oh my lands
girl that was amazing I could see an
expression on Demeter's face where he
went like oh wait my opponent has three
strikes this is it he realized it in the
moment
absolutely incredible it is amazing and
okay we're gonna stop the new one now
all right can Christopher you come back
I mean there's so little margin for
error and Marta gets a strike on the
fourth puzzle oh no you cannot afford
that in this format
no you cannot
marred up with a big big mistake that'll
be costly and now he's got to be perfect
the rest of the way essentially
yeah Krista for you is faster and
Dimitar is catching up however this one
strike is hurting a lot
now we're in 20
will they hit 30 in one minute
doesn't look like it maybe Christopher
but it is getting really close 26 now
seven for Christopher and still a
perfect record
who barely hit 30 in one minute
why did Dimitri why did mardov
get out of the taxi
Dimitar was not working
[Laughter]
puns because because my English is not
sufficient for it but this one
my puns I think are they they I I try to
find you know the lowest form of humor
That's My Style I love it strikes two
strikes four Dimitar and he's still
taking this one away
Christopher is a huge lead
and a clean record
34 that is not a great score to have
with two strikes III and Krista for you
in the rule 43 already unbelievable and
here's the problem it's not just that
Dimitar is going to lose this one he's
gonna lose this one with a huge score
and in the event of a 2-2 tie which is
likely this massive difference is going
to serve him out demeteros could get
moving and he's got to take a gamble
he's got to get to 45. get to 45 is his
goal Queen H2 he's not seeing it
oh Queen H2
and then we're G8 yep
he finds it eventually but it took him
so much time
that is tough shrink Christopher's lady
doesn't really have a chance to win this
one but can he at least get to a decent
score oh he is
I mean 10 difference
for up to 52 now what a score what
what is a solution here before no I
don't think so because Queen H3 there's
maybe E4 now Queen F1 Queen H3 oh my
gosh that was impossible
knocking
[Laughter]
and Dimitar does what I think he had to
do which is to get to 45.
well eight point difference there and
now it's one two one but look at
Christopher's total 104 points in total
that is what he needs because in the
case of a tie we count the the tie break
is uh based on the total score
we are guaranteed to get both of these
puzzle runs in because obviously neither
player can win with a 2-0 score and it's
going to be I think all about the
cumulative score I think a 2-2 tie is
very likely
let's see
yeah
on the same score pretty much 16 now
okay
looking good for both
but Timmy Turner got stuck on this one
okay he finds it
Christopher speed he's so consistent
that was a very hard one for the 26th
puzzle I mean it was like a maiden six
push that pawn push him baby
29 for Christopher you in the first
minute he's got 30
31 that's behind
gosh this is close
it is but Christopher is just grabbing
that lead and not letting it go he's so
fast and accurate
yeah so far no strikes
and he meets are kind of catching up
avoiding strikes on both players clean
there's something very satisfying about
seeing all check marks and no red X's
now watch me Jinx one of them
a mistake is coming by one of them I can
just feel it in the next couple puzzles
oh no
and see it
so far so good
all I see is green
yep
we're so good wow that was made in three
and there it is there it is it took a
while it took some time I did
Bishop B2 what a ridiculous move that
you have to find a queen D4 it's a
linear move Christopher with 43 and only
one strike not a problem here
oh this is
here is the second strike it's 44 all
Christopher has to be perfect from this
point on he cannot afford another
oh
did you see that
I have no idea what I just witnessed
that was I guess it just cut off some of
the moves Knight G3 and a mate
Christopher getting to 52 strikes oh
second strike
oh he had a chance there
Christopher taking his time
Queen F5 I think it's just Queen F5 I
don't know what he's
oh rookie six
[Music]
Gotta Go Gotta Go Gotta Go demons are
stuck
on two strikes he doesn't see Knight F3
and Knight G3 he got it wrong
oh my lands oh that is devastating
Christopher you now taking the lead two
to one look at that consistency by
Christopher 51 53 51 if you score over
50 on every run you're very very likely
to win against most people not named Ray
Robinson and jimus
yeah I mean this match is very close but
it looks like Christopher is on a roll
now can Dimitar mardov tie up the score
somehow it is very difficult for him and
not only does he need to win the actual
battle he's got to do it by 10 points or
more which is I mean unless Christopher
has a complete meltdown I think any
score of 45 or above is going to win it
for Mr you so he just has to be calm you
can slow down Christopher doesn't even
have to play this battle in order to win
it he just has to play to get 45.
yeah and he has been able to get that
score relatively easy so
yeah just don't make mistakes that's
pretty much all
yep it's as easy as that and mardov does
get the early lead here of three points
but
Christopher with no strikes
he's not taking uh risks here you can
tell that he is taking it a bit more
easier than the previous runs
yep you're exactly right and still
managing a very
serviceable 30 in a minute
both players actually were 30 in a
minute
yeah Christopher's just close this one
up right now he's cleaning this one off
he says I'm not giving away that 10
point lead
oh look at this look at this
that was so fast
and a fork and a win
five good Mart off keeping Pace here's a
trike
first strike for mardov
Christopher is going to win this one I
think that's it
yeah I mean Christopher is ahead one
point he can just sit and wait
at this point I mean neither of them
were moving
and Rook B4 is the move there very very
difficult because you have to calculate
that Queen end game here's the second
strike by Dimitar and this is it folks
Christopher you is gonna challenge jimis
unless we see a total Miracle here in
the last minute
yeah that is very unlikely uh despite
the fact that dimitarmartov has put an
excellent performance in this event
pulling off a miracle here like that
very unlikely even for a rare option no
that's it he's got in the third strike
and unfortunately Demeter mardov's time
comes to an end I would I would just
claim the win if I'm Christopher but
he's gonna finish this one off in style
and he's gonna challenge Jim is 46
Christopher gonna try to get 50 in the
last run
doesn't even matter
and we will gather rematch between
Christopher you and Demetrius ladopoulos
I'm excited for this one because the
previous matchup was really close
between them and Christopher honestly
has picked up his pace and picked up his
form
if he gets one more right he will have
scored 50 in every single one of these
four runs
the consistency that that takes cannot
be overstated and he gets done and he
gets to 51.
and he got it that's it
that's it
what a finish wow
what incredible consistency
yeah I mean Christopher you he is from
time to time he tends to be a little bit
inconsistent we saw in this other match
against Demetrios that you know he has
some weaknesses here and there but we
will have a rematch very soon and I'm
beyond excited for that one we will
indeed ladies and gentlemen you're
watching the puzzles World Championship
there is one more match in the losers
bracket to determine who will face Ray
Robson in the Grand Final you will not
want to miss this action we hope you've
been enjoying the show thus far and we
will be back with Krista for you against
Demetrius lodopoulos on the other side
of this short break
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
timelines yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
foreign
[Music]
hi
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the puzzles world
championship this is the current bracket
who will challenge Ray Robson for the
Grand Final will it be Krista for you
fresh off of a convincing win over
Dimitar mardov or will it be Demetrius
ladopoulos who went all the way down the
winter bracket before losing in very
convincing Fashion To None other than
Ray Robson himself what do you think of
my will dimitrios get his chance to
rematch Ray Robinson within the same
tournament
who Diana honestly seeing Christopher
use performance especially against
Demetrius I am not sure Christopher you
has shown great performance today and it
will be a very close match and it can go
anywhere both players have great chances
here and I find it really difficult to
pick a favorite here
I think this is going to be one of the
most evenly matched Puzzle Battle
matchups that we have really seen and
Christopher has just blown me away with
his consistency especially in the match
you just played against martov he needs
more where that came from because again
this is a best of four matchup right if
you get to three wins you win the match
if the score is 2-2 then the total
cumulative higher score wins the match
so will Jimmy's ridiculous top scores
take the cake or will it be
Christopher's consistency there's only
one way to find out
absolutely and we're about employers are
getting ready oh they already started
nice here we go let's go and Christopher
you is waiting again
they're gonna have to abort this one
come on Christopher
not able to make this his board is open
but I guess it's just glitching or
Frozen
and I really do think that they you know
probably a PC should be mandated for
future Editions
but
yeah they're gonna have to avoid this
one okay
yeah
you can restart as they did in
Christopher's last match
yep and
there's not a rematch just yet
but at least the players are ready to go
hard to see what is going on in
Christopher's screen okay there we go
okay he got one right so now we know
he's off
here we go ladies and gentlemen there
are two more matches to play this one
will determine who challenges Rey and
then Rey's Grand Final against the
winner of this match so buckle in
some more Puzzle Battle to watch
let's settle down and see who can
display more consistency
yep and Christopher you has a slight
Advantage here he's a little bit faster
than dimitrios but can he keep up this
pace can he continue
this speed
okay
G5
puzzles go by so quickly
yeah I mean you can barely register them
but Christopher is off to a blazing
start and again it's for jimus the key
is avoiding those early strikes they
have kind of plagued him in this edition
of the PB World Championship can he
display a cleaner performance here
yeah currently Christopher is I had five
points which is which is a massive Gap
37 now and dimitrios seems stuck on this
one okay he solved it but it took quite
some time
and it's allowed Christopher to develop
the six point lead the real question is
can I keep my voice alive
[Music]
40 now for Christopher but he is stuck
on this one
I think it's
I don't know what it is it's night I do
no night F6 oh you go to G4 incredibly
hard mode the retreating night move
anime the hardest move to find in chess
it was pretty much process of
elimination none of the moves that went
forward we're good oh two strips there
were two strikes in a row and Jesus
there's one by jimus
this is a Hess moment
[Laughter]
dollars uh oh you know whose fault it is
you gotta take that pawn and then you
gotta avoid stalemate oh Christopher
bingo
both players on 47 now two strikes so
close what's the move here is it Rook G3
it is
I think it's recording three and both
players stuck in the same position they
did solve it
48 plus it does not get closer than this
49 by Jim is and he gets to 50 no
where's Christopher he does oh he's
stuck on this one what is it though he's
gonna lose this one and he got three
strikes now
that is a win for dimitrios in the first
run he hits 50. against 48. it's a total
nail biter I mean this could have gone
either way those middle strikes by
Christopher he almost got two in a row
very uncharacteristic by Christopher you
let's see if he can score over 50 to
Rebound in the second matchup okay here
we go
yeah that was a tough one for
Christopher if he if it wasn't for the
fact that he got two strikes in a row he
would have had a great chance to beat
Demetrios in the first run
absolutely but you can't ruminate on it
because you don't have much time to
rebound and the players are Off to the
Races once again
Christopher you once again slightly
faster than dimitrios
oh the first mistake of Christopher you
whose fault was that I wonder who said
that he's a little bit faster than ever
so I don't remember which commentator it
was I don't recall that you can you
recorded
it was someone I don't remember I I
commentated with her once you know I
don't remember the name ah unfortunate
unfortunate maybe we'll have to look at
the footage back you know I yeah that's
a good call or not
all right then we choose ahead 32 now
looking better
Christopher's got to be careful one more
strike and he might be out of this event
back to the wall here
yeah dude it's okay one minute and 40
seconds left plenty of time still to
recover
and one strike is not the end of the
world at all Rook dd8 but Christopher
you slowed down just a little bit as you
can see
okay the Matrix is I had three points
now that that's a pretty big uh lead for
you know this little amount of time and
also the fact that Christopher is
already on one strike that is going to
make a difference for sure oh my God
that was a ridiculous tactic there that
you just saw with Rook to G6
Christopher Keeping Up with the
Kardashians for the time being
Knight D4 easy clap there oh look at
Demetrius
Rook F1 Queen D1 made in two that
actually looks so easy
yeah Andrew Tang had that one and
struggled with it
oh my gosh Christopher somehow keeping
up but jimis hits 50.
30 seconds left
you're still ahead I don't know what
this one is
I don't know what the solution is for
Christopher oh it's 96 and Queen no no
it's not a queen
things 53's pulling away is Demetrius
lidopoulos 54 that's it that's it bagged
it put it in the bag put that in your
pipe and smoke it or wait
53 and Christopher's not gonna make it
not in time
oh my gosh how backbreaking is that
it got so close in the end be believable
okay Christopher he has to win both of
the next two matches
his back is against the wall
yeah two nil for Demetrios and it is
still possible for Chrissa for you but
he really needs to win the next two and
he has an earliest strike once again all
right he's still saying this might be it
but if he can stay perfect for the next
30 puzzles or so he'll be right back in
at one strike is not the end of the
world
or is it it might be jimus is taking his
time you can see he's slowed down just a
little bit here he wants to make sure
that he stays perfect
yeah
they are spending a little bit more time
now
um but Christopher is still ahead but
barely but has Jim has just entered one
of those zones Ray Robson mode where he
just gets every puzzle right and he gets
it right very consistently consistently
seems like it but there's still two
minutes left
in this run
okay another one
all right
32 now still doing all right still
keeping it at one strike
okay black promotes there
37 Jim is suddenly in front and he gets
a strike oh it's not over and there's a
second
same problem
oh this is making things really
difficult for Christopher can he still
make it happen with two strikes and also
down on the score
uh looking very difficult keeping that
two-point lead and Christopher still
trying his best he ain't done yet G4 is
the made on H6 and he got oh nice find
oh Jim is with the second strike Bishop
C1 was made in one he missed it and now
Christopher has got a Fighting Chance
they're tied at 46. Jim is stuck I think
it's Knight F5 and Bishop E7 yes it is
and Kristen forgot it too
okay where's the mate where's the mate
is it 95.2 I think it's 95 but I'm not
sure and neither is jimus
gotta take a risk here maybe Queen H3
King F4 and G5 neither player is able to
fight it Christopher's gonna win this
one Crystal can claim it he does it oh
my God and Demetrius Joe Ian and
Christopher with a valiant fight can you
believe how he survived the two early
strikes unbelievable
insane however the problem not for
Krista for you is that he needs to win
with a three point difference at least
he must have claimed this one because it
was not looking good for him but in this
one he has to win with three points more
and that is a challenge against
dimitrios it is indeed and if dimitrios
can get to 50 or 51 this even if he
loses this battle this literally might
come down to cumulative score every
single point counts and let's see if
both players can avoid the early strikes
and survive the Jitters that accompany a
battle as important as this one there's
a lot of money on the line too I mean
this is this is for who this is for all
the marbles so who challenges Rey
yeah I'm going to the big final and for
those in the chat who are wondering why
did Christopher you claim the win he had
Stills plenty of time he wasn't two
strikes and if he had this puzzle
incorrect it would have ended in a draw
resulting in a match loss he had to Win
It won that one and he could by claiming
the win so indeed that's why
and as you're saying it's not enough for
him to win he has to win by at least a
margin of three points so far both
players keeping it cool
but Demetrios with a little bit of a
think there 93
and a mate oh and a strike
oh my gosh that's a costly oh no
Demetrius
and now Christopher you taking the lead
as well on the scoreboard oh
okay
can Christopher avoid a strike and he
gets a 45 and then he can really start
solving quickly with the freedom to know
that he can get one wrong and he gets to
40 without a strike
insane puzzles King B4 correct
no anybody gets a strike Bishop to C5
was winning
but he continues to stay composed both
players are actually 42-42 with a minute
left here we go
oh this is getting really tense
yeah oh a second strike for Christopher
unbelievable now he needs to be perfect
and Jim smells it
can Christopher maneuver his way into 43
yes he can it's tied up
oh this is really really tense 44 all
it's getting really close as well
Christopher needs to take a lead he
needs to take a lead he needs to win by
three and jimis is more than happy with
the tie so Jim is can be conservative
here he's got only one strike
Christopher he's unable to pull away
it's still tied
so even if he wins 20 seconds 48
I think this is gonna be I think that's
it hard for Christopher 49 Jim is just
making sure that Christopher can't get
that three-point lead
[Music]
three points more and Christopher ends
on three strikes that's it Demetrius is
moving on to the Grand Final against the
one and only Ray Robson we will have
another rematch between them we will
indeed ladies and gentlemen Demetrius
ladopoulos and Ray Robson this is
has iconic as Raphael Nadal against
Roger Federer I mean there are these
matchups that we look forward to every
single time and we're gonna get another
classic Ray Robson destroyed Demetrios
in their first matchup but now they meet
in the grand final of the puzzles world
championship for all of the marbles and
Amaya and I will have the call on this
final Puzzle Battle match when we return
here at the puzzles World Championship
go
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock up right here almost
there and you did it
oh what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
timelines yeah okay you bring a clock oh
I left my clock at home dude you idiot I
told you to bring it let's just go get
something to eat okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
January is a special time the Tata steel
super tournament is the Wimbledon of
Chess all of the greatest players in the
last half century and beyond have made
the wintry journey to vican Zay and
played and won there's a rook of seven
Shaq boom Rook takes D4 immediately
played in 2023 the Rainy World chess
champion Magnus Carlson returns in the
hopes of winning his ninth title
Tata steel is famous for its tournament
lineup featuring a creative mix of
superstars and super talents that always
guarantees Fighting Chess what a
devastating moment chess.com will be
bringing you the action the drama and
the emotions Live January 13th through
January 29th don't miss history in the
making
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the BowTech
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
foreign
[Music]
three two one
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
puzzles World Championship as we review
the bracket in preparation for the Grand
Final where Ray Robson will face
Demetrius ladopoulos
also known as jimis it's going to be a
matchup of the Aegis a rematch of the
match they played earlier in this season
as well and Amaya you know more about
this uh a rematch from last year as well
where their final was incredibly close
absolutely Naya they played last year in
the same championship and lastly with a
bit of a different format but they
played 15 puzzle battles and their
scores were ranging so race scores were
raging between 47 and 54 whereas Jimmy
scores range between 43 and 54. the the
puzzle battles themselves were super
close and Ray Robson actually barely won
because the effort score was only two
point difference of course Ray won
convincingly but still put quite a big
fight there and I'm really looking
forward to see that uh tonight again
even though Ray Robson went quite
convincingly earlier today against
dimitrios so let's see if Dimitrius can
still find this pace back up as last
year unfortunately for Demetrius Rey has
been Unstoppable this today I mean he
has been even by race standards in the
best form of his Puzzle Battle career he
has gotten 56 I don't think he's gotten
a single run below 52 and that is
unbelievable here they go dimitrios
needs to bring his a game and let's be
honest anime he needs to get lucky he
needs Rey to have an
uncharacteristically bad set of runs
exactly Dania once again everyone we are
back to Best of eight this is the Grand
Final in case Jimmy's wins this match we
will have another but best of four match
so let's see if we will have that happen
here but first the best of eight can
Jimmy's pull off a win here against
the one and only Ray Robson
let's see both sides starting pretty on
the slower side I mean it's 25 a piece
and 27 a piece neck and neck they go so
far but we've seen this every time from
Ray he doesn't try to win the puzzle
battle in the first minute he tries to
win it in the last 90 seconds that's his
strategy as he keeps it clean up to 30.
yeah I mean he he has this Pete as we
said countless of times earlier he has
this speed consistently throughout the
three-minute puzzle Rush run he may not
be as fast but he is accurate sharp and
has the same Pace all over the three
minutes and that is what is required to
be the winner here and there is the
first strike of Jimmy strike strike for
Jim is 37-36 and this is what Ray does
this is what I talked about in his
previous match he waits for the first
strike from the opponent and then he
speeds it up almost imperceptibly he
turns on the dial and he makes you
nervous and then he makes you get a
second strike just watch this in action
it's mesmerizing
yeah for now Geniuses ahead but for how
long is the question
[Laughter]
one minute left or is it Bishop E3 and
H6 it's Bishop B3
no it's 157. the difference
oh my Lord
timiso had 46 nah 47 he is doing it but
can he keep it up can he keep it up
indeed 48 he is keeping it up and Rey
has really slowed down here this is
resembling his first run in the last
match which he almost lost and can he
ladder Checkmate the king yes he can 47
and this is an easy one king H takes 48
race catching up but Jim is up to 49.
oh 24 seconds left on the clock is
getting very close oh
Ray's pulling away he's got 50 and Jim
is gets a third that's right third
strike oh man and Rey's continuing to
pull away and for his standards 51
nothing special but a very solid very
solid first run for Ray he's gonna get
53 unbelievable and can he get to 54.
he's cannot oh and it was checkmated one
G5 he was that close to getting 54. that
close
oh at this rate there's no chances at
this rate and am I the guy is
Unstoppable
yes Diana this is just so clinical by
Ray Robson he's not taking any risks
like many of us try to have as many as
possible in the first minute and this
causes us a lot of mistakes but Ray
Robson is just taking it easy one by one
same Pace not too fast not too slow and
that's how he gets to 50 because he
knows in the 40s in the 30s he knows how
to solve those puzzles exactly he is so
incredibly fast as soon as he gets to
the high 40s
and that takes the burden off and that
makes it unnecessary for him to take any
risks at all in the First 35-40 puzzles
I mean this is what makes him so
incredibly Unstoppable
now once again we see a repetition where
Jimmy's is ahead on the scoreboard but
he will he will he be able to keep this
up that is very unclear and now it's
tight again I mean it's so hard to
defeat Ray Robson
it is indeed and it's worth watching
anyway even if Rey's the favorite even
if the heavy favorite first of all last
year was very close second of all
don't you want to watch the greatest of
all time in a particular field I mean
it's I could watch him play himself
for eight matches
yeah I mean it's just phenomenal and
it's such a pleasure pleasure to watch
Ray Robson play in this event
um over and over again and just be
undefeated
yeah and it's the same thing again we've
been through this act before gymnast is
ahead by two he's ahead by three and
then at some point he gets the first
strike and Ray Robson takes off but
right now Jim is keeping it clean at 43.
and Ray catching up
43 a piece what was that what that was
were those chess moves like were that
has that even legal
47 with a minute left but this is danger
time for Jim is can he get it up to 50
quickly
47 for array
48 for Rey
Bishop takes H3 puzzles Ray kind of
taking his time Ray might get this one
wrong he doesn't know it no he doesn't
he gets it right he took his time and he
got it
oh but Jim is up to 50 both sides
51. this is gonna be a close one
very close one neither have the strike
oh my God there's the first strike from
James but Ray doesn't know this one he
might have to gamble 53 Jim is starting
to pull away but he's still ahead on the
score oh my God how is Ray doing this
he's up to 53. Jim is up to 54. his
biggest run yet raise up to 54 as well
he knows this one 55
a second strike it's over
Genesis isn't gonna get there
watch your clothes one Ray one again
this is insane wow Jim is best run of
the day and it's still not enough Ray
Robson is unbeatable
unbeatable
he does what is required nothing more
nothing less exactly whatever score
jimus gets raised like if he gets 50
I'll get 51 if he gets 54 I'll get 56.
whatever you get name a number I'll one
up you and the score is two nil Ray
Robinson is already knocking on the door
of yet another insanely convincing
Victory oh and Jim is tilting away
that's going to kill him
that's a killer
you cannot afford a single strike
against Ray Robson not even one
and Jim is you know he he has been
putting his soul into this final and it
still has not been enough can Rey
deliver the ultimate dagger and win a
third battle in a row
for now Ray Robinson is ahead and also
doesn't have a single strike it looks
like Demetrius is stuck on this puzzle
he got it right
and he continues 30 for Rey in a minute
so he's keeping up on the speed as well
two minutes now left in this run
players have such a crazy score in a
single minute of solving puzzles
yep and there's a mate on E6 and on F7
Rook takes G7 check for Rey and queen G4
smoothly executed
still hasn't lost the game Robson still
has not lost a single battle today
what a dominating performance
this is definitely oh and there's a
strike
one a second one for Jim they got the
same one wrong
and this is where that early strike for
Jim is going to hurt him so badly
yeah I mean one point difference but Rey
does not feel the pressure here he has
only one strike
and obviously Rey is dominating but as
someone in the chat points out Jim is
only one person can give Rey this kind
of competition so let's not pretend that
this is easy for Rey it's been very
close it's not over yet and jimmis is
the only one in the world who can make
Rey work for his money kind of quite
like this
absolutely I mean both players are
phenomenal at puzzle rushes they know
their puzzles they have been practicing
for hours and hours and hours that said
Jim is getting a third one wrong
race
gonna rack up the point total here just
to make sure that even if Jim is ties
the score it might not matter we're
building it up to 50.
oh getting a second strike it was Queen
takes F6
he's gonna get 50. no pressure at all
he's just getting more and more points
as he can afford to get a third strike
no
it's over three now
this might be wow all she wrote if Ray
can win the next one
yeah
that would be a huge huge score let's
see if Demetrius can at least pull out
one win here he has been doing a
fantastic job in this event
let's see if he can make it happen
what's crazy is that 51 might be the
lowest score that Rey has achieved in
all of today 51 is his lowest score most
people would hang their hat on 51 being
the highest score they achieve in their
entire lives
last year the scores were flunk trading
a bit more than this but it was never so
steady it was never so uh steady around
the 50s it's insane
yeah
and there's
okay I don't even know what's going on
on the board
but it's something's happening and at
the end a check mark appears on the
screen
31 for jimius
32.
he has the speed
but the ray is catching up he is
catching up over here
he's definitely not in a rush whatsoever
yeah seven what was that
Ray just coasting he's coasting he's
saying listen
jimis might do the damage on his own I
don't need to go crazy and he's right
Jim is with a strike
Madness
and look at Ray Robinson he's just
taking his time no he could easily just
pass on a puzzle and go next but nope he
needs to get it right those strikes
matter a lot in the end
35 but he is on two strikes now Jimmy's
on two strikes 46 he has a huge score
but two strikes with 50 seconds left on
the clock oh and Ray look at Ray
catching up right there catching up and
Ray basically is he sets a goal for
himself and he goes for it and he says
listen I'm 52-53 is all I need given the
gym is already has two strikes Ray can
take more of a gamble in these puzzles
jimis has to take his time because he
cannot afford to get it wrong there's 50
by Rey and Jim as you see he's got to
take all that time
to make sure absolutely sure that he
gets it right that gives Ray the time
that he needs to build up a little
advantage
and where's the king gonna go 51 for Jim
is he's catching
catching too oh Ray Scott on this one
and Jim is with a third strike Ray's
gonna win that's it that's it and Ray
you can claim to win but he's not but he
doesn't even want it he wants to get 54.
he wants to get 55. and he does and he
gets it and he gets 56. no not quite oh
my gosh
wow
this is this is unbelievable I mean
again you called in nmi whatever gymnast
gets Rey will get like two more than
that it doesn't matter what it is
unbelievable and this means it's 4-0 for
Ray Robson one more win for Ray and he
is the next well next this thing once
again
for the hundredth millionth year and Rey
has still not not lost a single battle
if he wins this one he keeps that streak
alive and this will definitely be the
first time in his Puzzle Battle career
that he will manage to pull off this
particular feat what an impressive feat
it is this was one of the strongest
fields that we've had with new young
players and Andrew tang and jimus and
Ray had to beat twice no problem
at all
yeah this is absolutely crazy and it's
just so inspiring to see that you don't
have to be so fast I mean of course he
is you know solving them at God's speed
but there's faster solvers than them
than him however he the accuracy the
fact that he can solve those ones in 30s
40s even 50s at the similar pace is what
makes him so strong and that it's just
so hard to uh to deal with
The Rook V1 and Bishop B2
trapping the queen of Ray just taking it
easy here he's down by four but
I mean it just doesn't matter what the
score is you can close your eyes and
wait
until there are 60 seconds left in the
Run
and that's an array
really shows his beastly nature Queen F6
wow
okay Jim is still clean though he's not
willing to give it up give it up just
yet
42 now for genius he's ahead but there's
still one minute and 15 seconds left on
the clock here
wow
Queen H E what what what in the world as
speechless as you are but jimis is up to
46 with no strikes this might be his
best run yet he's up to 47 with no
strikes he keeps him he's keeping the
lead Ray needs to turn on the Jets here
with no strikes 49 49 but this is where
Ray has managed to catch up each and
every time 50 for jimis he keeps it
going
can Ray get up to 49. 51 jimis might win
this one
oh my gosh jimis is on fire 50 for Ray
and Ray score up to 51. he's got 20
seconds to catch up
a draw wins the match for Ray there's a
strike for Jimmy
there is a strike for Ray 54. Jim is my
win this one
10 seconds left oh my gosh
jimis is gonna get it he's still in it
he's gonna win
53 by Rey
[Music]
oh my God he got around he lives to
fight another day
and he lives to fight one more battle
Ray
his undefeated streak has come to an
independence of an insane
Stand Down performance by jimus who
remains in the match it's not over yet
if he does this every time and Amaya
well you might get some butterflies in
Ray's stomach here before long but he's
got plenty more attempts
this is something that was an insane run
by James that was incredible it was so
clean almost until the very end insanity
unbelievable but here they go again Ray
it's not like he had a bad run there he
got 53 that's basically his average
score it doesn't matter jimas was
Unstoppable and he gets an early strike
that might kill him
oh oh that is trouble trouble in Denmark
yeah what do you do against this I mean
race
strike he shakes his head uh he knows he
knows what's up you cannot afford this
against Grandmaster Robson and Ray
capitalizing perfectly
and he's not going to be happy that his
perfect streak was spoiled but
regardless this is going to be one of
the most amazing Puzzle Battle runs that
we have ever seen
count the eggs after they've hatched
as the expression goes it looks very
tough though raise the head on the
scoreboard 36 to 34 two strikes for
Jimmy's I mean
yeah a miracle should happen for uh for
Jim is to win this one and nothing short
of a miracle but right now he's managing
to catch up obviously the problem is he
gets one more wrong but it's immediately
over
and Ray Robson is determined to end it
here and now he's got 42 he's got a
two-point lead and he's going with
lightning speed up to 43 and down to 44.
and one minute left 45 what is going on
on the board Jesus
so you would say Knight F5 but that's it
T5 oh it's official that's his third
strike
that this is it strike
incredible
champion
free Robson wins the puzzle World
Championship once again
with a completely dominant effort and
he's going to he's not even going to
claim the win he's going to try to set a
high score
uh as a little Encore here in his last
run of the day he's got 52 and Counting
make it 53. can he get it up to 56 can
he even make 57 I don't think so give me
that 57 right here
yeah but he needs he needs a couple
really quickly
he's gonna get yeah this is tough take
the Rook take the rook and take the
other Rook he's got enough to 54.
all right that's it folks Ray Robson is
our champion once again
and what a final performance a smile on
his face and a deserving smile indeed he
crushes his second in command Demetrius
ladopoulos and there ladies and
gentlemen is the final bracket
wow what a spectacular
matches we had today here we see the
Grand Final between Ray Robson and
dimitrios ladopoulos finishing in with a
score of five to one Ray Robson did not
win it undefeated but he did win it very
convincingly he deserves puzzles world
champion of 2023.
oh my God goodness I just need a breath
I just need a breath after what we just
watched and it's not just the fact that
Ray wins it's how he wins it's the fact
that he has everything under control
from the first minute until the last
it's somebody who just knows what the
result is going to be before he starts
playing
incredible what a performance we started
all the way yesterday with the
qualifiers that was so incredible to
watch race sticking out with a
phenomenal score of 58 and today he
proved his value again in the puzzles
World Championship what a phenomenal
performance by him a phenomenal
performance indeed I cannot believe that
this tournament lasted only two days
there has been so much action over the
last two days yesterday we saw the
qualifiers we saw so many deserving
players who did not quite make it they
included Liam Putnam they included
minlay Jeffrey Zhang a lot of players
didn't quite make it make it happen
Andrew Tang he squeaked by he almost
defeated Jima so we could have been
talking about a completely different
outcome if one puzzle has been solved
correctly and that's really the magic of
Puzzle Battle the fact that everything
can really come down to one second to
one puzzle to one move to one
combination to one tactic
and Ray Robson had everything in the bag
today and Amaya it was an absolute
pleasure commentating these last two
days ago I apologize for my voice
it was a lot of shouting a lot of action
you get a lot of you said a lot of
wonderful things you did a great job it
was a pleasure with commenting with you
as well and I hope everyone in the chat
wherever you are had a wonderful time
watching these two days uh it was
phenomenal it was awesome a hearty
congratulations to Grandmaster Ray
Robson the puzzle world champion and of
course so congratulations to his
opponent Demetrius ladopoulos who fought
so valiantly and had so many great
moments so we congratulate Ray I'd like
to thank our producer Matt uh for the
excellent work on the broadcast last
couple of days and our entire wonderful
team at chess.com Tata steel begins
tomorrow with just a amazing kotery of
flares they include the world champion
you will not want to miss tomorrow's
broadcast that starts at 5 a.m Pacific 8
A.M Eastern and 2 p.m Central European
Time Hess and such Dev we'll be bringing
you the commentary but for now from the
puzzles world champion championship this
is women's International master and
Amaya Kazarian and Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinski saying goodbye until Tata
steel begins tomorrow so long
see you
[Music]
three two one
foreign
[Music]
thank you